Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 137. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove, wie immer. Und ich muss wieder noch ein bisschen kämpfen mit dem tollen Mischpult, wo eigentlich immer alles ganz super funktionieren sollte. Aber jetzt bin ich auch schon wieder ganz dabei. Und ja, 137 heißt die Ausgabe, die dann endlich mal wieder ein technisches Thema auf den Tisch legen wird, nachdem hier viel über Kultur und Gesellschaft gesprochen wurde in den letzten Ausgaben, wie es sich ja auch gehört für einen Podcast der Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft im Untertitel hat. Trotzdem muss man auch immer mal wieder auf die Technik zu sprechen kommen, damit man weiß, wie die Realitäten da draußen eigentlich wirklich aussehen. Und ja, ich will mich eines Themas annehmen, als auch so ein bisschen immer so diesen Nimbus des Buches mit sieben Siegeln hat. Jeder redet darüber, keiner weiß eigentlich wirklich Bescheid. Genau genommen heißt das Thema Streaming, also das Echtzeitübertragen von Audio und Video und vielleicht auch sonstigen Datenströmen in der Zukunft, who knows, vor allem aber eben Bild und Ton, das, was ich auch selber hier in meinen Radiosendungen häufig mache und was jeder irgendwie auch gerne mal machen will, da das Internet ja mit Bandbreiten und so weiter zunehmend weniger spart und sich abzeichnet, dass jeder so sein eigener Sender sein kann. Das ist ja der alte Traum. Und um diesen Traum jetzt mal zu besprechen, begrüße ich den Gast, Niko.
Es freut mich sehr, hier zu sein.
Niko, Nikolai Longolius. Du bist ja auch so ein Webwerker der alten Stunde. Seit wann bist du schon so am Gerät?
Na, seit 1995, 96 begleite ich mich, glaube ich, Computer.
Und du hast dich dann aber relativ schnell schon in diese Bild- und Tonfraktion begeben, oder?
Na, es hat so ein paar Wellen genommen. Ich habe früher ganz viel Musik selber gemacht, deshalb ist mir dein Studio sehr sympathisch mit all den blinkenden Lichtern hier. Man muss dazusagen, dass ich Tim gerade wie ein Schneekönig über einen neuen Audio-Mischer freute. Und habe dann aus einer Laune heraus eines der ersten deutschen Internet-Radios gegründet gehabt, Lion Radio, wo wir...
Lion Radio?
Genau, wie das Löwenradio, weil wir damals in der Löwenstraße saßen, in Hamburg. Und haben im besten Sinne Radio aus dem Wohnzimmer gemacht und genauso wie hier uns an einen Tisch gesetzt, der bei Weitem nicht so professionell war, wie das, was du hier auffährst, und haben einfach Audiosignale aufgezeichnet und diese in ein MP3-Format gewandelt und am Ende in das Internet gestellt.
Was habt ihr da gesendet? War das jetzt so ein reiner Musiksender oder was?
Wir haben ganz viel Musik gesendet und uns fürchterlich dabei betrunken.
Also das war sozusagen nur so ein Vorwand für so besäufendes Orgien?
Wir hatten eine Episode in der Mitte, wo wir immer tatsächlich live in der Sendung zur Tankstelle gegangen sind, um uns zwei Bier zu holen. Dabei haben wir einen Song gespielt und kamen dann wieder und hatten die Zeit gestoppt.
Also richtiges Internetradio?
Richtiges Internetradio, genau.
Aber wann war das? 1995?
Nee, das ist gelogen. Ich glaube 1997 ging das los. Und es ist inzwischen auch angezweifelt, ob es das erste deutsche Internetradio wäre. Bei Wikipedia findet man, glaube ich, das Radio Regenbogen oder sowas früher wäre. Aber es war halt auch nie als professioneller Event gedacht. Das war halt ein Witz. Und dafür war es aber sehr gut.
Hat denn überhaupt jemand zugehört?
Es waren sogar erstaunlich viele. Und das wirklich Bewundernswerte war, dass die meisten der Zuhörer beim Zuhören das Gefühl bekommen haben, ach, das kann ich auch. Also wir waren offensichtlich so schlecht, dass unsere Zuhörer selber spontan das Gefühl hatten, dass das muss besser gehen. Und dann habe ich in der damaligen Zeit so eine Anleitung geschrieben, die orthografisch eine Katastrophe ist. Aber wie gründe ich ein Internetradio? Und die hat mehreren hundert Kleinstpodcastern irgendwie dazu verhäuften, ihr eigenes kleines Podcast...
Zum Podcasten in dem Sinne gab es ja damals noch gar nicht.
Dem Begriff gab es noch nicht.
Aber auch das Konzept nicht.
Nein, in dem Sinne, das Konzept hatten wir ja schon, weil wir haben einmal in der Woche eine regelmäßige Show gemacht, die sich auf einer Seite als Progressive Download angeboten wurde. Also man konnte auf den Knopf drücken und dann spielte die Musik sofort. Und das Tolle an der Zeit war halt, dass das ging. Es war quasi erst mal dieser erste Moment zu sagen, ich kann jetzt auf Sendung gehen und meine eigene Radioshow machen. Und dieser Moment zum ersten Mal auf einer Party jemandem zu begegnen, der das wirklich hört und nicht zum engsten Freundeskreis gehört, war ein ganz toller. Und das war diese verrückte Radiozeit. Das ist dann alles mit der ersten Dotcom-Blase auch so ein bisschen da niedergegangen, weil davor stand, wie es, glaube ich, bei, ich habe das Gefühl, jeder zweite deutsche Schlipsträger hat in diesen Jahren versucht, Venture-Kapital zu vergeben. Und so standen bei uns irgendwie auch drei Schlipsträger, die dann mit den Platzen der Dotcom-Blase auch wieder weg waren. Und dann löste sich das alles auf. Dann habe ich vom Ton zum Bild gewechselt und viele, viele Jahre für Spiegel TV gearbeitet. Habe tatsächlich noch mein 10-jähriges Jubiläum dort erlebt. Das ist kurz vor der goldenen Uhr.
Dein 10-jähriges Jubiläum als was? Als Spiegel TV-Mitarbeiter?
Als Spiegel TV-Mitarbeiter. Das ist dann, glaube ich, die goldene Nadel am roten Band.
Wunder, dass das seit 10 Jahren gibt. Da reden wir jetzt von Spiegel TV als TV und nicht so sehr als im Internet.
Genau, im TV gab es, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es Spiegel Online da am Anfang überhaupt schon gab. Ich hatte viel mit TV zu tun.
Spiegel Online gab es, aber es gab halt nicht TV auf Online.
Bei Weitem nicht. Dann war ich bei der Gründung von vielen Fernsehsendern dabei, XXP, ich habe dann ein Jahr für einen Discovery-Channel gearbeitet, habe DMAX gemacht, also ich kenne irgendwie diese Fernsehwelt ganz gut. Und bin dann am Ende von dort wieder zurück zum Internet gekommen und habe so ausgelotet, was jetzt eigentlich mit Filmen im Internet so machbar ist. Hab diese Anfangszeit auf Spiegel Online mitgemacht, wo es verächtlich von den Redakteuren immer Briefmarkenfernsehen genannt wurde. Und habe dann angefangen, eigene Konzepte für Web-TV-Auftritte zu entwickeln und mich jetzt selbstständig gemacht mit einer Firma, die genau das macht, die Web-TV-Sender gründet.
Ja, wir machen hier Briefmarkenradio sozusagen. Wir hatten ja vor ein paar Wochen uns kennengelernt im Rahmen dieses Experiment, Bundesradio, was wir gemacht haben, wo wir auch ganz fleißig gestreamt haben. Und jetzt hast du ja wirklich da auch ein bisschen deine Hände drin. Ja, abgesehen von deiner interessanten Hintergrundgeschichte, wollten wir eigentlich erstmal so ein bisschen in die Geschichte dieses Streamings als solchen eintauchen. Ich meine, mittlerweile ist es irgendwie ein großer Hype, das wissen irgendwie alle. Es gibt da zahlreiche Plattformen, was weiß ich, Ustream und wie sie alle heißen, Livestream, Streaming hier, Streaming da. Jeder muss jetzt irgendwie sein eigener Fernsehsender sein und seine Fresse ins Internet halten. Das ist okay, so ist das. Aber das technische Verständnis, das scheint mir doch recht gering zu sein. Was war denn aus deiner Perspektive eigentlich so ein bisschen der Urknall des Streamings im Netz? Also wann hat denn das erste Mal wirklich jemand Ton, von Bild kann man da glaube ich am Anfang noch gar nicht reden, Ton irgendwie live ins Netz gebracht?
Also vielleicht muss man vorneweg einmal erklären, was Streaming überhaupt ist. Genau, was verstehst du darunter? Die beiden Welten, die sich da gegenüberstehen, und es ist schlimm, dass es schon auf der einen Seite ein Fachbegriff ist, aber es ist einmal das Progressive Download gegenüber dem Streaming, wobei man glaube ich sogar noch davor anfangen muss, das kennt man glaube ich aus den 90ern auch noch, dem einfachen Download.
Der gewöhnliche Download.
Ja, aber das war natürlich die Art und Weise, wie zumindest Videos am Anfang im Internet verbreitet wurden, funktionierte darüber, dass irgendwo ein Link auf eine Videodatei lag und ich warten musste, bis diese komplett auf meinen Computer runtergeladen war und dann das Video erst öffnen konnte. Das war quasi der Start der Filmverbreitung im Internet. Das was danach passiert ist, ist, dass diese Progressive Download-Technologie aufkam. Das bedeutet letztendlich nichts anderes, als dass ein schlauer Fuchs herausgefunden hat, wenn ich eine Tondatei von Anfang an hören will, brauche ich das Ende ja noch gar nicht, sondern es reicht mir halt, den Anfang zu haben. Das können wir später noch darauf eingehen. Es gibt dabei technologisch noch ein Problem, dass man die Header an den Anfang ziehen muss, oder dass man die zumindest besitzen muss, aber eigentlich ist es nichts anderes als das, dass mein Audioplayer anfängt, die Ton- oder Bilddatei dann wiederzugeben, wenn er den ersten Schnipsel bei sich hat. Mit dieser Technologie funktioniert heute beispielsweise auch noch YouTube. Die Progressive-Download-Technologie ist sicherlich die am weitest verbreitetste Medienverbreitung-Technologie, die so im Internet...
Ja, weil sie ja vor allem den Vorteil hat, dass man sowohl früh angucken kann, als auch nicht so viel Bandbreite braucht, wie ein Streaming unter Umständen erfordert.
Das ist, glaube ich, nicht ganz korrekt mit der Bandbreite. Ich glaube, man kann sogar eher von dem Gegenteil sprechen.
Nein, was ich meine, ist, dass wenn... Also, es gibt ja Sites, die ihren Content nur per Stream anbieten. Das hat dann so und so viel Kilobit. Wenn einfach meine Internetverbindungen die nicht hergeben, dann kann ich das nie sehen.
Ah, so ungedacht, das stimmt.
Ja, und da gibt es irgendwie so ein paar Kunden im Netz. Hat man irgendwie mal ein dichtes Netz oder ist irgendwo in der Pampa und so, dann gibt es halt einfach nichts. Progressive Download hat dann zumindest den Vorteil, dass ich nur lange warten muss, an Schubstrichen. Dann aber dann irgendwie das ganze Lokal habe. Insofern ist das an sich eine sehr elegante Lösung, dieses Bandbreitenproblem.
Das stimmt. Wenn ich viel Geduld mitbringe, kann ich mit so einem Download der Datei tatsächlich auch hochqualitative Medien runterladen, obwohl meine Bandbreite das eigentlich nicht hergibt. Jetzt hat das Progressive Download noch ein Problem, dass es mitbringt, ich kann nicht zu anderen Stellen des Films springen. Ich kann zu keiner Stelle springen, die ich noch nicht heruntergeladen habe. Bei YouTube sieht man das sofort oder bei irgendeinem anderen, man kennt das auch in den Video- und Audioplayern, es gibt quasi immer zwei Fortschrittsbalken am unteren Ende. Der eine zeigt mir die Position des Films, an der ich mich gerade befinde, und der andere Balken, meistens etwas schwächer und im Hintergrund, versucht, mir grafisch zu visualisieren, wie viel von dem Film ich bereits auf meinen Computer runtergeladen habe.
Wobei, es gibt Ausnahmen. Ich habe das auf Chaosradio CCC, CDE zum Beispiel auch bis vor kurzem gehabt, muss ich sagen. Ich will es auch wieder einbauen. Derzeit funktioniert es nicht, wegen eines 32-64-Bits-Navus. Aber es gibt Erweiterungen für Web-Server, so Scheinstreaming. Das heißt dann immer Streaming, ist aber eigentlich so ein Direct-Excess. Das heißt, wenn dem Kleinen das irgendwie gesagt wird, sprich, Kleinen heutzutage sozusagen, in der Regel halt so eine Flash-Kapsel, wo man dann sozusagen irgendwo hinklickt, wo man es noch gar nicht geladen hat, dass man eben dem Web-Server sagt, jetzt würde ich aber ganz gerne nochmal die Daten laden, aber ich fange halt schon bei Sekunde sowieso an. Und dann benutzt man eben HTTP, um quasi nach vorne zu blicken.
Genau. Ab da wird das technologisch vom Verständnis her schon relativ tricky, was dort im Hintergrund geschieht. Es gibt für den Lighty-HTTP-Server eine sehr einfache Bibliothek, wo man das einbinden kann. Genau die, die gerade kaputt gegangen ist, die grundsätzlich aber sehr gut funktioniert. Dort passiert im Hintergrund Folgendes. Jetzt muss man wieder zum Verständnis von komprimierten Video- und Audio-Dateien kommen. Die Player, also die Software, die selbst den Video- oder Audio-Stream wiedergibt, braucht quasi so eine Art Inhaltsverzeichnis von dem, was sie zu erwarten hat. In diesem Header steht drin, was für eine Art Video das ist, was sozusagen dieser Player zu erwarten hat.
Wie lang das Teil ist.
Wie lang das Teil ist, wo er Key Frames findet. Kann man später vielleicht noch mal drauf eingehen? Du hattest schon gesagt, es gibt schon ein Chaosradio Express über Kompressionsformate. Genau.
Wobei, da sind wir nicht in die Frames reingegangen, sondern ein bisschen mehr um die Container und wesentlichen Encodingsachen.
Dann erkläre ich das vielleicht am Rande doch noch einmal schnell, was quasi bei Video und Audio, aber vor allen Dingen bei Videokompression heute quasi der Trick ist. Der Trick, um es ganz einfach zusammenzufassen, warum diese Dateien so klein werden, ist, dass die Herren Wissenschaftler herausgefunden haben, dass es eine relativ ineffiziente Art ist, Videos abzuspeichern, indem ich jedes Vollbild wie ein Foto behandle. Also während bei der MP3-Kompression der Großteil der Kompression ja über so ein Audio-Trick lief, nämlich dass sie gesagt haben, wir können die Frequenzbereiche, die sowieso keiner hört oder wahrnimmt, weglassen und damit die Datenmenge reduzieren, ist es bei der Videokompression eher ein anderer Trick, nämlich dass die Herren sagen, wenn ich in einem Film zehn Sekunden lang eine weiße Wand filme, dann muss ich nicht 25 Einzelbilder in der Sekunde, hätte man so durchschnittlich ungefähr im Moment, dann muss ich nicht 10 mal 25 mal ein unkomprimiertes oder ein JPEG-Bild abspeichern, sondern es reicht, das Ganze als Differenzbild zu beschreiben. Das heißt, ich speichere an der ersten Stelle ein Vollbild der weißen Wand oder der Vase oder was ich auch immer filme. Und in den Differenzbildern danach steht eigentlich nur noch drin, es hat sich nichts geändert. Meine Differenz zum vorgegangenen Bild ist Null. Und diese Information ist sinnvollerweise sehr klein. Das bringt aber ein Problem mit sich. Das kennt man auch aus der Anfangszeit des Internets, zum Beispiel aus dem Reel-Player sehr gut. Das war immer ein, also zumindest kenne ich den Effekt sehr gut. Nämlich, wenn man diese Key Frames verpasst und die Bildinformation nur aufgrund der Referenzbilder zusammen sammelt, dann entstehen so Situationen, dass ich vielleicht ein Auto sehe, aber das Auto bekommt auf einmal Lippen und redet, weil ich quasi die Differenzbilder des Interviews danach sehe, aber noch das Key Frame des Autos.
Oder man guckt halt gerade so einen Pixar-Film, wo die Autos ja sowieso alle Lippen haben und reden.
Das hast du geschafft. Ich hatte erwartet, dass jetzt Pornografie kommt, war deshalb quasi schon viel mehr aus dem Konzept gebracht. Genau, das heißt, diese Filme bestehen, es ist tatsächlich in Wahrheit noch etwas komplizierter, aber gehen wir jetzt mal am Moment davon aus, sie bestehen aus Vollbildern, die tatsächlich Fotos sind, JPEGs, die da weggespeichert werden. Und die werden gefolgt von nicht mehr ganzen Bildern, sondern nur noch Differenzinformationen.
Wobei dann in der Regel immer Teilbereiche betrachtet werden, je nach Kompressionsalgorithmus, was dann eben auch zu dieser Blockbildung dann nicht selten führt, wie man so aus MPEG kennt. Genau. Das heißt, umso besser das funktioniert, umso kleiner ist die Datei, sie sieht trotzdem noch gut aus, sozusagen. Und Key Frame ist dann sozusagen immer ein vollständiger Frame, der sozusagen keinerlei Referenz benötigt, sich auf nichts bezieht, sondern die vollständige, komplette Bildinformation enthält, die sinnvollerweise beim Encoding genau da gemacht wird, wo zum Beispiel ohnehin schon so ein Bildwechsel ist.
So, und diese Key Frames sind eine wichtige Information, die mein Player am Anfang besetzen muss, weil wenn ich an irgendeine beliebige Stelle des Films springe, in der Zeit leiste, dann muss mein Wiedergabegerät wissen, wo der nächste Key Frame von dort aus gesehen ist, und zwar in die Vergangenheit gerechnet, wenn ich nicht zufährweise genau selber einen Key Frame treffe.
Bei einer guten Kompression kann es schon sein, dass mal ein paar Sekunden lang kein Key Frame kommt, oder?
Genau, da sind wir quasi an so einem klassischen Problem im Internet, nämlich die Frage, wie das Verhältnis der Key Frames ist. Wenn ich sehr viele Key Frames setze, kann ich sehr komfortabel in dem Film hin und her scrollen. Aber ich habe eine größere Datei. Wenn ich sehr wenig Key Frames setze oder im Extrem sogar nur einen Key Frame an dem Anfang, dann ist es wahnsinnig aufwendig, zu einer anderen Stelle des Films zu springen. Jetzt kommen wir zurück zu diesem Lighty-Trick des HTTP-Streamings. Die machen nämlich Folgendes, wenn ich an einer Stelle in der Mitte des Films springe und damit quasi das Kommando an den Server gebe, gibt mir ab Minute 32 alle weiteren Informationen dieses Films. Dann tut der Server so, er baut quasi in diesem Moment live für mich einen Film zusammen, der erst ab Minute 32 beginnt. Das heißt, der Server nimmt sich zuerst den Header des Films, schreibt den an den Anfang und gibt mir nach dem Header die Bildinformation ab Minute 32. Also es ist tatsächlich serverseitig relativ technologisch aufwendig.
Klar, weil da muss ja das Modul für FLV-Videos und für MP4 und man muss ja im Prinzip komplett parsen, verstehen, wissen, wo die Frames sind und dann irgendwie neu zusammenbauen. Aber hat natürlich den riesen Vorteil, also gerade jetzt sowas, was ich hier bei den Konferenzsachen nicht war, da weiß man manchmal, die erste halbe Stunde will ich mir sparen. Denk ich immer an Hollywood-Filme, die man sich anschaut. Und wenn man dann sagen kann, okay, gehen wir einfach zu der ersten Stunde, dann ist mir egal, ob das irgendwie auch noch mal ein, zwei Sekunden dauert, das Ganze zu berechnen. Ich habe mir auf jeden Fall eine Stunde gespart.
Genau. Und das Verfahren hat den enormen Vorteil, und da kommen wir jetzt zu dem Kernproblem des Streamings, dass Streaming-Technologie bis heute einfach wahnsinnig proprietär und wahnsinnig teuer ist. So das heißt quasi, egal, welche Player auf dem Markt mit ihrer Streaming-Technologie um die Ecke kamen, es waren durchweg Sachen, die nicht trivial aufzusetzen sind, die in den meisten Fällen mit sehr hohen Lizenzgebühren verbunden waren und die auch solche Probleme wie Load-Balancing, also was mache ich eigentlich, wenn ich mehr als 50 Zuschauer habe, unendlich verkompliziert haben gegenüber so einer einfachen Webserver-Nummer, wo man sagt, naja, dann fahre ich halt noch ein Webserver hoch. Und das ist, glaube ich, der eigentliche Grund aus heutiger Perspektive, warum Streaming bei Otto Normal-Verbraucher nicht wirklich den Durchbruch erzielt hat und warum du, glaube ich, heute auch noch zumindest so ein unbestimmtes Gefühl mit dir herumträgst, dass diese Streaming-Technologie mit dem Bösen im Bunt steht.
Ich jetzt im Besonderen oder wir alle? Na, ich selber nicht so. Gut, jetzt sind wir schon vom 1. zum 5. gekommen. Ich blätter nochmal kurz zurück. Also, du hast ja gesagt, wenn man über Streaming redet, muss man auch erstmal über den normalen gewöhnlichen Prekariats-Download reden und dann sozusagen die fortgeschrittene Variante des Progressive-Downloads, die im Prinzip eigentlich eher eine Kleinoptimierung ist. Abgesehen davon, dass, wenn ich dich richtig verstanden habe, die Datei in einer bestimmten Ordnung sein muss. Dass man nämlich so mit den ersten Bites, die man sowieso schon mal gelesen hat, weiß, was kommt. Sprich, in einem Header muss drinstehen, wie lang ist das, wie groß ist sozusagen die Datei, auf die ich zugreife.
Wo befinden sich die Key Frames?
Und sagen wir mal, einfach je nach Format, was man da wirklich durchwühlt, überhaupt eine Möglichkeit einzuschätzen, wohin man denn springen muss, um an einer bestimmten Stelle zu landen. Also quasi auch dieses Verhältnis von Bites zu Zeit. Was ja auch nicht ganz einfach ist, wenn da dieses ganze Encoding ja keinen linearen Fluss ergibt. Mal hat man mehr Daten für ein paar Sekunden, mal weniger. Welche sind denn da alle Dateiformate im gleichen Maße für geeignet?
Um gestreamt zu werden?
Ja, um so Progressive Download schon mal. Bei Progressive Download geht man ja immer von vorne. Vergiss das. Mir ging es jetzt sozusagen um dieses nach vorne springen. Also ich mache jetzt mal die ganze Klammer zu. Also wir haben Progressive Download und dann haben wir halt Streaming. Streaming heißt im Prinzip, die Daten werden mehr oder weniger genau zu dem Zeitpunkt gesendet, wo sie dann auch konsumiert werden, um einfach den Overhead so niedrig wie möglich zu halten. Vorteil ist einerseits, man schickt einfach auch nicht mehr Daten, als gebraucht werden. So ein Progressive Download, der bei YouTube losgeht, selbst wenn man sich irgendwie nur die ersten zehn Sekunden anschaut und das Netz ist schnell, dann sind halt irgendwie fünf Minuten geladen. Das ist sozusagen sinnlose Datenmenge. Das wollen sich manche Leute sparen. Hat natürlich den Nachteil, den wir schon vorhin erwähnt haben, dass reicht die Bandbreite eben nicht, um das in Realtime zu machen, dann steht man eben doof da. Da gibt es ja dann verschiedene Strategien, auch die Bitraten sozusagen flexibel vorzuhalten. Das heißt, das ist das eigentlich, was man meint mit Streaming. Also der Begriff wird ja extrem inflationär verwendet. Ja, irgendwie Streaming ist alles, aber eigentlich geht es darum. Jetzt gibt es da viele Standards. Aber vielleicht fangen wir doch vorne an. Das war ja meine Eingangsfrage. Wo fängst du denn an?
Ich habe versucht, dir auszuweichen, weil ich es tatsächlich nicht weiß. Ich kann nicht sagen, wer wo den ersten Audiostream in die Welt hinaus geblasen hat.
Ich will jetzt nicht wissen, wer die Glühweine erfunden hat. Aber meine Wahrnehmung ist, eigentlich hat Real seinerzeit die Welle losgetreten im Netz. Vielleicht gab es irgendwo eine Lösung, aber dass das eine nennenswerte Verbreitung hatte, ist ja nicht so.
Real Audio war der erste große Player im Internet, die Streaming-Technologie an große Broadcaster-Netzwerke lizenziert haben und damit überhaupt erst mal angefangen haben, in beträchtlichem Maße Bild- und Ton-Streams in die Welt hinaus zu blasen.
Das eine war sozusagen, dass sie einen guten Encore hatten. Das heißt, sie waren in der Lage, Audio in erträglicher Qualität recht klein zu rechnen. Und das Streaming-Protokoll, was sie verwendet haben, war das dann auch eine eigene Erfindung? Oder haben die da auch schon sich auf Standards gestützt?
Ich habe das damals wie wild gemacht. Das tut so, als sei es ein offener Standard. Es ist dieses Real... Es heißt so ähnlich wie das... RTSP heißt das von denen und RTMP ist das von Flash. Ich weiß es, um echt zu sein, nicht ob es damals ein offener Standard war oder nicht.
Also sie sind irgendwann auf RTSP gegangen. Ich weiß bloß nicht, ob sie das von Anfang an getan haben. Also RTSP, Real Time Streaming-Protokoll, ist ein richtiger Internet-Standard. Ist sozusagen der kleine Bruder von RTP. Die beiden arbeiten dann eben auf UDP bzw. auf TCP-Basis. Und das ist ja eigentlich das, ja bis heute eigentlich, das dominante Protokoll, oder? Gibt es noch irgendwas anderes, was eine nennenswerte Verbreitung hat?
Ich glaube, das dominante Protokoll heute ist das von Flash eingesetzte, von Adobe eingesetzte Protokoll, das RTMP, ein proprietäres.
Dominant, weil jetzt Flash so viel verwendet wird?
Aber vielleicht bei der Protokollfrage, um da nochmal anzuschließen, der ein wesentlicher Vorteil dieser Streaming-Protokolle, vielleicht muss man noch etwas früher anfangen, aber ist, dass eben die Protokolle versuchen, wenn irgendwie möglich, UDP als Transportstream anzusetzen. Das bedeutet, dass der sendende Server nicht darauf wartet, dass der Client zurückmeldet, er hat das Paket bekommen, sondern das einfach mal so rausgesendet wird, wie einfach auch ein Radio- oder TV-Sendemast, den ich in die Republik hineinstelle, einfach mal so sendet und nicht nachfragt, ob alle Zuschauer eigentlich einen guten Empfang haben. Das spart in der Differenz ungefähr 10% Overhead. Also das ist so eine entscheidende Stelle, wo man sagen kann, da war es intelligent, das Protokoll zu wechseln, weil ich 10% der Last spare, die ich sonst einsetzen müsste. Und sonst ist, glaube ich, die Historie dieser Streaming-Server, da zumindest die großen Player, die dann relativ schnell aufeinander gefolgt sind, jeder hat versucht, so ein Häppchen von dem Markt abzubekommen, waren eben Real-Audio, wo aus heutiger Sicht unverständlich ist, warum sie es nicht geschafft haben, so eine große Marke zu bleiben. Also dieser Real-Player, muss man ja sagen, ist heute eigentlich aus dem Alltag fast verschwunden. Ich glaube, er ist auch nicht mehr standardmäßig mitinstalliert.
Ja, aber warum sind sie untergegangen, weil sie irgendwie scheiße Software gemacht haben und ihre ganze In-Your-Face-Politik nicht zu ertragen war. Allein diese Exkurse, die man machen musste, um diese Software herunterzuladen über viele Jahre, das ging ja gar nicht. Es war einfach von Sales-Droids, glaube ich, vernichtet worden, deren Assets.
Jetzt könnte man natürlich sagen, dass die beiden Attribute, die du gerade genannt hast, scheiße Software zu machen und doofes Marketing zu haben, auch auf viele erfolgreiche Leute zutrifft. Das finde ich jetzt ist noch kein, wäre noch nicht der Ausschlag.
Sie haben sich auf jeden Fall extrem angreifbar gemacht. Ohne Not. Sie waren überall verbreitet, aber sie haben es einem dann irgendwie nicht einfach gemacht, ihre Sachen zu nutzen. Und andere haben es dann einfacher gemacht.
Ich erinnere mich auch, es ging früh damit los, dass man in diesem Installationsprozess des Reel-Players diverse Toolbars und Sachen mitinstallieren musste. Und es war wahnsinnig schwer, sich durch diese AGBs so durchzuklicken, dass man nicht gleichzeitig mitwerbung.
Ja, dann auch so ihre Aufteilung. Und dann hatten sie irgendwie noch Gold und Premium. Und dann haben sie versucht, sich das bezahlen zu lassen. Und diese ganzen tausend Versionen, die zueinander inkompatibel waren. Also es war einfach...
Aber aus heutiger Sicht, was für ein historischer Fehler, diese Vormachtstellung aufzugeben.
Ja, ich war Ihnen keine Tränen nach, muss ich sagen. Aber Tatsache ist, sie haben das sozusagen gemacht. Also es war ja dann eine Weile lang... Ich meine, das Hauptproblem war natürlich, alles war halt proprietär. Es war diese RA-Files oder RAM-Sachen und so weiter. Es war halt alles undokumentiert und es war einfach nicht möglich, da auch mit freien Tools zu arbeiten.
Und ich weiß, dass auch die Streaming-Server selber wahnsinnig teuer waren in der Anschaffung. Ich weiß, dass ich mir damals mit dem Webradio auch mal eine Quote, also ein Angebot, habe zuschicken lassen, was die eigentlich so wollen, wenn wir unser Radio darüber verbreiten. Und ich glaube, sie wollten damals fast 10.000 DM haben für diesen Streaming-Server, für eine Lizenz. Also das war so eine Größenordnung, wo ich einfach lachen musste, als ich es gesehen habe.
Ja, da haben sich auch eine ganze Menge Leute irgendwie real eingetreten und sind bis heute noch nicht losgeworden. Ich meine, wenn man sich so Sender anguckt wie den RBB zum Beispiel, die sind heute noch gezwungen irgendwie mit Reel zu senden, weil sie irgendwann mal sich ein, was weiß ich, wie viele Jahre während dem Vertrag irgendwie für die Zukunft abgeschlossen haben. Diese Zukunft ist schon längst ad acta gelegt worden. Trotzdem müssen sie sich jetzt mit diesem Kack noch rumschlagen. Und anstatt auf offene Standards zu setzen, muss man halt immer noch diesen Quatsch ertragen. Das nervt einfach nur noch. Aber ich wollte jetzt mal so ein bisschen auf dieses Streaming als solches kommen, damit man so ein bisschen ein Gefühl zu bekommen. Also mit RTP und RTSP, ich meine, die Ideen, die dort geboren wurden, die sind ja auch in allen anderen Streaming-Protokollen wahrscheinlich mehr oder weniger präsent. Also da hat ja keiner jetzt wirklich was Neues erfunden, sondern es gab nur so Detailzwänge, die dann noch nötig waren, da weiterzuschreiten. Hauptproblem, denke ich mal, ist vor allem diese Problematik von Firewalls, dass man eben so ohne Weiteres immer nicht mit dem ganzen UDP hin und her kam, bzw. auch natt. Also die Realität, dass einfach die meisten Leute bei ihrem DSL-Anschluss in einem IP-Nummerbereich arbeiten mit ihren Computern, der eben nicht im Internet so sichtbar ist, macht es halt natürlich schwierig, da direktional zu empfangen. Also das Senden ins Heim war eigentlich schon immer ein Drama und das ist dann beim Streaming auch ein Problem gewesen.
Wobei das heute auch, muss man dazu sagen, mehr so eine gefühlte historische Last ist. Heute haben eigentlich alle Anbieter vernünftige Fallback-Verfahren, um genau das auszugleichen. Also wer sich heute, egal von welchem großen Anbieter, einen Streaming-Server bei sich hinsetzt, hat dieses Firewall-Problem.
Ja klar, aber es dauerte auch erstmal so, gefühlte fünf bis zehn Jahre, bis diese ganze Infrastruktur, sowohl die Server als auch die Router, die dann auch irgendwelche Tabellen und temporäre Lookup-Geschichten aufrechterhalten mussten. Und dann gab es auch zehn verschiedene Implementierungen, wie diese ganzen Traversal-Verfahren dann funktionieren. Und jetzt hat man dann auch noch dieses Problem, dass dann natürlich so ein Software-Bereich, so eine Melange da entsteht, die einem dann auch nicht weiterhilft, weil im Zweifelsfall funktioniert dann immer irgendwas nicht und man weiß halt nicht, was. Deswegen gibt es jetzt gerade so einen Move in Richtung HTTP, da können wir noch später darauf zu sprechen kommen. Aber wie kann man sich denn jetzt so dieses hin und her zwischen einem Streaming-Client und einem Streaming-Server, und zwar jetzt mal so ganz klassisch diesen Fall RTP, RTSP, im Fokus, wie kann man sich das so vorstellen? Also wer redet da mit wem, auf welche Art und Weise?
Genau, also es läuft serverseitig eben eine Streaming-Applikation. Gehen wir jetzt mal davon aus, es ist relativ egal, ob es sich dabei um einen On-Demand-Abruf auf dem Server handelt, also um eine Datei, die sich auf dem Server physisch befindet, oder um einen Livestream, der weitergegeben wird. Da können wir gleich auf Details noch angehen. Es gibt als erstes halt einen Handshake, der der Client kommt um die Ecke, sagt, hallo, hier bin ich und ich hätte gerne diesen Film von dir. Dann kann serverseitig noch eine Validierung stattfinden. Darf der das? Wie auch immer ist es relativ einfach, da so eine Applikationslogik zu implementieren. Nach diesem Moment findet fortwährend eine Kommunikation zwischen Server und Client statt, wo der Client dem Server quasi sagt, wo er sich gerade befindet, welche Pakete er gerne als Nächstes hätte, wie es um seinen Buffer steht, was benötigt der Client, um weiter senden zu können. Und der Server versucht, sich mit einer hohen Intelligenz das zu versorgen mit dem Ziel, dass am Ende möglichst wenig unsinnige Pakete durch die Republik verschickt werden.
Also nicht mehr als nötig und auch nicht weniger als benötigt.
Dabei, bei diesen keine unnötigen Pakete, sind viele, viele intelligente Sachen noch dazugekommen, so wie eben moderne Streaming-Server tatsächlich auch, ohne dass der Client das merkt, verschiedene Qualitätsstufen des Streams wechseln können. Das heißt, wenn der Server merkt, kleinseitig scheint mit der Bandbreite gerade was nicht zu stimmen, dem läuft gerade der Buffer leer, kann der Server live den Stream auf eine schlechtere Qualität wechseln, ohne dass der Stream unterbrochen wird. Es besteht sogar bei modernen Streaming-Servern die Möglichkeit, wenn, wir reden hier von Veranstaltungen, wo bei großen Anbietern Hunderte, wenn nicht sogar Tausende, Streaming-Server in eine Art Wolke laufen und den kleinen anbieten. Das heißt, wo der Client sogar im laufenden Programm den Streaming-Server wechseln kann, wenn quasi der Anbieter merkt, der raucht gerade ab oder muss sich aus Wartungszwecken entnehmen. Aber das Kernprinzip des Streamings ist, es findet eine fortwährende Kommunikation zwischen Client und Server statt, wo der Client anmeldet, welche Pakete er gerne hätte und der Server ihm diese Pakete übermittelt.
Wobei die jetzt permanent, wenn ich es richtig verstehe, verhalten, sind die quasi über einen Stream, also über eine Verbindung, also über RTSP sozusagen dauerhaft miteinander verbunden. Das ist sozusagen ihr Chat. Und über RTP, über UDP letzten Endes gehen dann die eigentlichen Datenströme. Das heißt, das eine ist einfach nur sozusagen, da hat man das Handy am Ohr und sagt, schick mal, schick mal, schick mal, schick mal und über einen anderen Kanal rauschen die Daten einfach ran. UDP im Vergleich zu TCP, kann man auch nochmal kurz erwähnen. Für die Leute, die IP kennen, ist das selbstverständlich. Aber die beiden Protokolle sind ja sozusagen das Herz von TCP-IP. UDP ist eigentlich so das nackte IP. Das heißt, da kommen die Pakete an oder nicht. Das hat den Vorteil, dass sie ankommen oder nicht. Also man muss sich sozusagen darum kümmern, wenn irgendwas nicht gekommen ist, dass es dann unter Umständen noch mal geschickt wird. Aber genau das ist ja beim Streaming eher die Falle. Wenn man TCP verwendet, dann kümmert sich der ganze Network-Layer schon selber darum, dass irgendwie Retransmission gemacht wird. Aber das ist natürlich im Falle von einer Echtzeitübertragung eher hinderlich. Und deswegen geht es da eigentlich auf solche Sachen. Und deswegen hat das ja auch eigentlich lange gedauert, bis man sich irgendwann mal getraut hat, zu sagen, jetzt setzen wir sogar auf so ein High-Level-Protokoll wie HTTP auf, was ja einfach an TCP sich festgebissen hat. Aber da stehen wir trotzdem noch mal nach hinten.
Das schicke vielleicht an der Stelle, um es nochmal zu sagen.
Eine Frage. Diese Bitraten-Negotiation, ist das sozusagen ein Standard-Feature des Protokolls? Und das müssen eigentlich alle Server so machen? Oder ist das irgendwie das irgendwie proprietary Erweiterungen? Wie ist es da mit der Kompatibilität zwischen Client und Server?
Na also einmal setzen ja alle Player tatsächlich auf andere Protokolle. Also es stimmt ja nicht, dass alle auf dem untersten Layer das Gleiche verwenden würden, sondern als großer Anbieter, wenn man jetzt Real Audio nimmt, Quicktime, die tatsächlich untenrum auch RTP, also die halten sich noch dran. Microsoft selbst hat dieses MMS, glaube ich, als Protokoll mitgebracht. Flash setzt auf zwei komplett eigene Protokolle dahinter. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass alle eine gemeinsame Basis hätten und untenrum die gleiche Sprache sprechen und obenrum nur eine andere Farbe haben.
Ist klar, aber ich wollte jetzt mal auf RTP und RTSP, weil das ja eigentlich so als der Standard gilt. Ich meine, alles andere sind irgendwelche proprietären Sachen und RTP, RTSP ist halt standardisiert und nicht wahr?
Genau. Und die Frage ist, ob diese Bitrate-Negotiation Teil der Protokoll-ISO-Vereinbarung ist und ich weiß es nicht.
Das klingt ja immer alles erstmal so sehr einfach, aber man hat ja gesehen über die Zeit, die eigentliche Schwierigkeit erwächst ja aus der Gesamtkomplexität von all den beteiligten Sachen. Das fängt dann erstmal schon mal an bei dem Encoding, was man verwendet. Dann hängt es sowohl für Video als auch für Audio. Dann hängt es davon ab, worin das eingepackt ist. Diese Container-Formate, das ist ja auch immer noch ein geführter Kampf. Auch wenn ich so den Eindruck habe, dass jetzt der MPEG-4-Standard ein bisschen Ruhe bringt in dieses ganze Spiel. Das heißt, das muss halt alles zusammenpassen, bevor Kleinen und Server zusammenreden können. Dann eben solche Spirenzchen, wie diese Bitratten-Degotiation. Das ist halt die Frage, inwieweit das herstellerübergreifend funktionieren kann. Aber eigentlich ist es immer noch so, man hat immer so den passenden Kleinen zu dem passenden Server. Das ist wirklich so eine übergreifende Standardisierung. Gibt es eher die Ausnahme?
Du hast natürlich an der Stelle schon recht, dass es auf dem Mit-RTP schon einen offenen Standard gibt, an den sich alle halten könnten. Tun sie aber nicht. Das heißt, natürlich kann ich heute mit dem VLC-Media-Player mich theoretisch auf mehrere Streaming-Server connecten. Es gibt sozusagen schon Bastellogik, mit der ich solche Sachen zum Funktionieren bekommen kann. Aus Anbietersicht, aus Broadcastersicht, ist das Wort Standard da natürlich ein sehr großes Wort für etwas, was nicht verwendet wird. Das heißt, jemand, der sich dort an alle Standards hält, hat wahrscheinlich am Ende das Problem, dass ihn keiner empfangen kann, weil sich außer ihm keiner an diese Standards hält. Das ist aus heutiger Sicht das eigentliche Problem. Deshalb muss man, glaube ich, heute, wenn man eine neue Streaming-Plattform oder was auch immer aufbaut, zunächst einmal, was da perspektivisch geschieht, steht auf einem ganz anderen Blatt, aber zunächst einmal dem am weitest verbreitetsten Playern ins Auge sehen. Das sind aus heutiger Sicht sicherlich der Windows-Media-Player und vor allen Dingen der Flash-Player. Dort läuft man genau in das Problem der Propeller-Protokolle.
Aber hat iTunes nicht auch eine massive Verbreitung gefunden im Rahmen des Erfolges des iPods?
Ja, aber als Streaming-Media-Player? Also ich bin mir nicht sicher, aber es sollte schon...
Mit jedem iTunes kommt eine QuickTime Installation, da ist dann diese Fähigkeit ja auch dabei. Aber das ist natürlich richtig. Microsoft ist natürlich weit verbreitet mit seinem Kram und genauso natürlich Flash.
Und Microsoft und Flash machen beide natürlich auch die beste Lobbyarbeit, muss man an der Stelle sagen. Sie haben einfach die besten Schlipsträger. Die in den Konzernzentralen rumlaufen und denen erzählen, was für tolle Sachen sie da machen und an was für viele tolle Standards sie sich halten und wie isozitifiziert sie sind. Ja, aber das sind ja dann auch die wichtigsten.
Wir erfüllen alle unsere eigenen Standards.
Das ist bei Microsoft immer schon toll, wenn sie das tun. Also das heißt, dieser Kampf wird gerade noch ausgetragen. Ich glaube, es ist im Moment auch schwer. Ich glaube, wenn man einen Etappensieger erklären müsste, dann wäre das sicherlich Adobe. Aber alleine an der Geschichte Reel merkt man, wie viel so eine Etappe wert ist, wenn man auch nur einen Fehler macht. Und das, was du gerade angesprochen hast, das, was im Moment mit diesem HTML5-Standard, Videotag, HTTP-Streaming versucht wird, als Standard zu verankern, könnte so eine neue Antwort auf so ein Problem werden.
So, das heißt, jetzt, was hatten wir denn? Also, gut, Reel hat sozusagen Streaming-Audio, später dann auch Streaming-Video, quasi hohfähig gemacht. Also, das haben wir auch den Sprung zu Video dann geschafft und waren dann eine Zeit lang genauso stark. Und sind dann irgendwann gefühlt so von Flash übernommen worden. Also, jetzt, was sozusagen diese Präsenz, die reale Präsenz im Internet betrifft. Dann kam YouTube und die große Welle, und damit hat sich das dann auch für das erste zementiert. Jetzt wird meistens da eben kein Streaming gemacht, aber bei den schon erwähnten Plattformen, hier Ustream und so weiter, wird ja dann eben auch diese Fähigkeit von Flash, auch die Kamera auf dem Rechner mitzunutzen und sozusagen auch hochzuladen, sozusagen auch als Quelle zu dienen und nicht nur als Ausgabepunkt. Das hat natürlich dann den nächsten Boom eingeleitet. Was ist denn drin in Flash alles? Also was können die denn alles in Bezug auf Streaming?
Also einmal hat Flash, liegt selbst ja gefühlt in 100 verschiedenen Versionen heutzutage auch noch vor. Deshalb ist es relativ schwer, die Frage zu beantworten. Flash hat seit der Version...
Nimm einfach die letzte. 10?
Man muss es quasi in dieser Historie schon einmal durchgehen. Die Videofunktionen von Flash waren ab Version... Das heißt, das erste, was Flash unterstützt hat, war letztendlich gestreamtes MPEG-2-Video. Das war aktuell bis Version 9.1. Irgendwas, schieß mich nicht tot. Das ist eben nicht genau der erste neuner Player, sondern einer später, der dann eben diesen Befreiungsschlag gemacht hat und endlich H264 als Videoformat unterstützt. Das heißt, seit dem neuner Flash-Player ist es möglich, H264, kodierte Videos. H264 hat ein Problem, weil da drauf dieses MPEG-Software-Patent liegt. Ich bin da, ähm, ich...
Kann auch nochmal draufkommen.
Ich bin da vielleicht nicht der Richtige, um ins Detail zu gehen. Aber auch das bringt Probleme mit sich. Es ist nicht einfach der offene Standard, von dem man denken möchte. Das ist jetzt alles sorgenfrei. Aber H264 ist halt erst mal ein ganz fantastischer Video-Standard, um Filme in einer guten Qualität klein zu rechnen und sie von A nach B zu werfen. So. Ähm, der Flash-Media-Server liegt inzwischen auch in zwei Versionen auf. Und es gibt konkurrierende Produkte dazu. Das ist auch neu in diesem Markt. Die versuchen, die gleiche Technologie zu implementieren. Es gibt einmal mit Red 5 bei Flash einen Open Source Streaming-Server, die das Protokoll reverse-ingeniert haben und leider noch nicht die Verbreitung von H.264-Videos unterstützen, sondern das nur in so einem Branch machen, der ich habe zweimal versucht, ihn zu installieren.
Das heißt, sie unterstützen sozusagen nur FLV, also das Container-Format von Flash.
Genau, sie unterstützen FLV.
Du hast gesagt, MPEG-2, also soweit ich weiß, ist ja ihr primär verwendeter Codec ein H263, sozusagen der alte Sorensen-Video-Codec.
Und dazwischen kam noch einmal VP6, das hat niemand so richtig verstanden. Das wurde noch einmal auf eine vollproprietäre Lösung von ON2 gesetzt in der Videocodierung, wo es keine freien Video-Encoder oder Transcoder gab, sondern man musste den von ON2 für wahnwitzig viel Geld lizensieren. Und zwar an der Anfangszeit roundabout so was wie 5000 Euro pro Prozessor-Lizenz, die Videos codiert. Ich glaube, das waren so die ersten Angebote, die man da bekommen hat. Und H264 war deshalb gegenüber dieser VP6-Welt so ein Befreiungsschlag von Adobe. Auf einmal gab es frei zugängliche Encoder. Jeder bei sich zu Hause kann mit Bordmitteln oder zumindest mit Open Source-Tools die Videos herstellen, die benötigt werden, um sie mit einem Flash-Player wiederzugeben. Das war toll und neu. Serverseitig ist es so, dass es, ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt komplett ist, aber ich sehe es so, dass es Moment 3-Player gibt, die in ungefähr dieser absteigenden Reihenfolge Relevanz haben. Die größten sind sicherlich Adobe selber mit ihrem Flash-Media-Server, der heute in zwei Versionen vorliegt. Einmal in einer Version, wo er praktisch nur dazu taugt, Videos und Audios zu streamen. Dort deutlich günstiger an den Lizenzgebühren wurde. Und ein anderer, der dieses volle Communication-Potenzial eines Flash-Servers ausnutzt. Das heißt, hier hat man eine programmierbare Server-Engine, die eben in jeder Hinsicht Interaktionen zwischen Client und Server unterstützt. Um mal ein ganz einfaches Beispiel zu nennen, Chatprogramme, Computerspiele, solche Sachen. Das Gleiche gibt es von Wauser Media, heißt die Firma, glaube ich, die für das gleiche Geld auch einen sehr stabilen Server zur Verfügung stehen, der deshalb so attraktiv ist, weil er sehr einfach zu lizenzieren ist auf den Cloud-Computern von Amazon.
Wauser?
Wauser.
Was schreibst du das?
W-O-W-Z-A.
Man muss schon richtig was einfallen lassen, um noch eine freie Domain zu kriegen.
Also Wauser baut auch einen Flash-Streaming-Server, der sehr einfach zu lizenzieren ist, aber man muss ihn eben auch lizenzieren. Und mit RedFive gibt es seit mehreren Jahren einen Open Source Flash-Streaming-Server auf dem Markt mit dem Manko versehen, dass man eben erst VP6-codierte Videos mit dem streamen kann, noch keine H264-codierten Videos, wo man eben wieder in diesem Lizenzierungsproblem drin steht.
Ja, benutzt das eigentlich irgendjemand, dieses VP6? Ich meine, ist das wirklich in the wild?
Ja, VP6 war und ist immer noch der Standard für Videokompression gewesen. Also das wird jetzt langsam abgesetzt, aber ich weiß, dass von einem der größten deutschen Medienhäuser, dass sie gerade in der Größenordnung mehrerer neu wagen, sich ihre VP6-Lizenzen haben verlängern lassen. Also das heißt, die machen schon noch Umsätze. VP6 hat tatsächlich, das war so ihre Lebensversicherung am Ende, noch die offizielle Implementierung des H264-Codex. Also sie sind irgendwie auch die Firma, die offiziell supported by Adobe wie auch immer. Also sie haben da quasi noch so eine…
Also die machen sozusagen da auch die H264-Geschichte für Adobe?
Genau.
Okay, verstehe.
Und da haben wir jetzt ein vernünftiges Update und kodieren jetzt eben auch vernünftige H264-Videos, wobei man eben heute dazu sagen muss, dass es mit X2400, wie heißt die Zahl, 264 H264, eine offene Implementation des Codex gibt. Und das heißt, jeder mit FFmpeg oder sonst wie aufgesetzten GUIs darauf selbst hochqualitatives H264-Video erzeugen kann.
Denkst du nicht auch, dass es jetzt einfach mal durch ist? Das ist jetzt eigentlich der Weg schon in Richtung H264, zumindest bis aufs Weitere, ist jetzt erst mal sicher?
Ja, das dachte ich und bin dann wirklich eines Besseren belehrt worden, weil die mit diesem HTTP-Streaming, vielleicht kommen wir technologisch gleich nochmal da drauf, aber es ist quasi eine neue Idee, wie man Videos oder eine sehr alte Idee, wie auch immer man das dreht, wie man Videos im Internet verbreiten kann. Und auch dabei musste man sich auf einen Videostandard einigen. Und was ist geschehen? Sie hauen sich die Köpfe ein. Und auf einmal ist jetzt wieder Orktheora im Spiel, weil dieses H264 eben, jetzt kommt man, jetzt geht ein Riesenfeld auf mit diesen Software-Patenten. Man muss sich eigentlich H264-codierte Videos beim MPEG-Konsortium lizensieren lassen. Das macht das ganze Ding höllisch kompliziert. Das heißt, wenn man da nicht mit so einem Viertelbein in der Grauzone stehen will, ist H264, zumindest wenn man das in den USA machen will, ein kompliziertes Feld. Und mit Oxeora steht dem gegenüber tatsächlich ein komplett freier Codec, der mit diesem Problem nicht behaftet ist.
Okay, ist gespeichert. Jetzt müssen wir mal aufpassen, dass wir nicht zu sehr in die Breite gehen. Ich wollte noch mal kurz ein bisschen zusammenfassen, was wir jetzt eigentlich uns erarbeitet haben. Klar ist, Flash stellt derzeit die mit Abstand populärste Streaming-Plattformen dar. Vor allem durch die massive Verbreitung im Client. Die Problematik ist vor allem, wenn man es streamen will, dann hat man entweder die Software von Adobe, die ist teuer, oder es gibt halt dieses Wauser. Und dann gibt es noch dieses RedFive, das Open Source ist, aber was H264 nicht unterstützt. Das heißt, man muss so oder so irgendwie Geld ausgeben. Man will natürlich die Kosten immer gering halten. Das ist eben so einfach nicht. In diesem Flash selber steckt drin der alte Scheiß. Also damals noch Sorenson Spark, der Coleg, den sie sich gekauft haben, der im Prinzip nichts anderes als die Implementierung von H263 war, was halt ein Vorläufer von dem jetzt so hoch gelobten H264 ist, aber im direkten Vergleich einfach technisch schon doch noch eine Generation zurückliegt, weil es nicht so viele Finessen kann, mindestens, genau. Als Zwischenschritt haben sie sich von On2 noch diesen VB6-Kram eingeholt, der durchaus auch deployt wird. Aber eben einfach mal nicht gerade besonders offen ist. Und das zeichnet sich jetzt eben auch ab, dass auch im Flash in zunehmendem Maße H264 delivert wird. Man hat es gesehen, vor allem YouTube hat ja dann relativ schnell diesen Weg eingeschlagen. Das Ganze ging ja dann auch ein bisschen einher mit der Weigerung von Apple, auf dem iPhone irgendwie Flash zu deployen. Aus welchen Gründen auch immer. Tatsache ist, die haben gleich gesagt, Leute, wenn ihr irgendwie Videos im Internet übertragen wollt, da gibt es irgendwie einen Standard, der heißt H264, macht doch einfach. Und vor kurzem haben sie ja dann auch ihre eigene Streaming-Lösung vorgestellt, da kommen wir auch gleich noch drauf. Vor allem, ich kann mir diesen Kasten Streaming-Server Flash irgendwie zumachen. Also kurz gesagt, es gibt keine Open-Source-Variante, um selber Flash-Streaming zu machen. Man muss so oder so Geld in die Hand nehmen, es sei denn, man setzt nur auf die alten Dateiformate. Das heißt, wenn man jetzt eine eigene Streaming-Infrastruktur aufbauen will, ohne viel Geld zu haben, dann ist man eigentlich gezwungen, auf irgendwelche RTSP-basierten Sachen zu gehen. Aber auch da ist es schwierig, eine Kompatibilität zwischen Server und Client herzustellen. Weil es gibt sehr viele Clients, die alle irgendwie unterschiedliche Fehlerlagen haben. Und ich weiß gar nicht, gibt es überhaupt irgendwelche Open-Source-Video-Streaming, Audio-Video-Streaming-Server, die taugen?
Es gibt mit IceCast eine interessante Open-Source-Implementation.
Aber IceCast macht doch nur Audio, oder?
Nein, die machen auf Video inzwischen.
Ach echt?
Die können Okthiora streamen. Ich habe das selber noch nicht aufgesetzt, mir aber sagen lassen, dass das interessant ist. Sonst ist es als Open-Source-Variante nochmal der Quicktime-Streaming-Server hat einen Open-Source-Branche, der sich Darwin-Streaming-Server nennt, mit praktisch dem gleichen Funktionsumfang. Der funktioniert sehr gut. Man prügelt sich am Anfang einmal mit Konformitätsdokumenten, weil das, was die unter einem MPEG-4-Container verstehen, nicht unbedingt das ist, was andere darunter verstehen. Wenn man erwarten würde, man wirft einfach so einen MPEG-4-Fall dagegen und der verbreitet ist, dann wird man je enttäuscht. Aber wenn man sich einmal anfängt, an das zu halten, was Apple an der Stelle für Standards erklärt hat, dann funktioniert er sehr gut.
Wobei die standen sich jetzt im Wesentlichen auf den Was-ist-in-der-Datei beziehen. Das heißt, sie setzen eine bestimmte Informationsanreicherung in einer mp4-Datei voraus, damit sie das ordentlich streamen können.
Das Problem ist, dass H264 auch nicht gleich H264 ist, sondern es gibt eine ellenlange Liste von Profilen, mit denen man H264 codieren darf, und die unterstützen alle unterschiedliche Features. Also das, was man heute gemeinen als einen Video-Codec bezeichnet, sind eigentlich zehn, in denen unterschiedliche Features je nach Profil freigeschaltet wurden.
Aber dieses Baseline, das ist sozusagen die kleinste Stufe, die taugt auch schon zum Streaming.
Die taugt auch schon zum Streaming.
Wenn man da noch dieses Hinting da reinmacht, oder was? Was hat es denn mit diesem Hinting auf sich?
Also hauptsächlich ist es wirklich so dramatisch, weil das nicht einmal gekommen ist und gesagt wird, wir lösen dieses Problem jetzt einfach einmal, dass man keine Radiosendungen mehr drüber machen muss und sich den Kopfzock treffen soll.
Ich kenne das halt noch so, dass wenn man vor Encoder-Software steht, die halbwegs breitbandige Optionsvielfalt anbietet, dann kommen sie halt auch immer mit hin und fragen, möchtest du das jetzt dann auch im Internet streamen? Genau. Damit ich da meine Hints reinmachen kann. Also was landet denn dann in dieser Datei, was über die normalen Key Frames und so weiter, die encodeten Audio- und Videospuren hinausgeht? Was landet da noch drin und warum, wer braucht das zu welchem Zeitpunkt?
Also um nicht zu kompliziert zu werden, das Einzige, was sich da wirklich großartig ändert, ist, dass sie den Header nicht an das Ende der Datei schreiben, sondern an den Anfang.
Aber wer schreibt denn einen Header ans Ende?
Fast alle Encoding-Softwaren, weil die Informationen, die man in den Header reinschreiben muss, hat man ja erst, wenn man das Ding fertig geschrieben hat.
Dann sind sie zu faul, nochmal den Anfang zu spulen. Das heißt, das war sozusagen einfach nur die Laziness der Software über all die Jahre, die Streaming sozusagen nicht ernst genommen hat, sondern man hat halt einfach ein Video gemacht.
Genau, und dann den Header ans Ende geschrieben.
Und die normalen Player haben dann sozusagen, wenn sie eine Datei geöffnet haben, immer erst mal am Ende gelesen.
Genau.
Kopf am Arsch sozusagen.
Und das macht auf meiner eigenen Festplatte halt nichts aus, weil der Kopf, ob der da einmal ans Ende der Platte oder an den Anfang springt, das ist auch wirklich wurscht.
Aber im Internet ist das natürlich eine andere Geschichte. Das heißt, Hinting ist nichts anderes als Header am Anfang? Oder ist das noch was anderes? Gibt es nicht auch noch so ein bisschen...
Ich eile da so ein bisschen, ob es tatsächlich, ob sie in die Datei selber noch was mit reinschreiben. Aber der große Unterschied, warum sozusagen man oft das Problem hat, dass Dateien, die ich bei mir codiert habe, im Internet einfach nicht so funktionieren.
Aber ist das da nicht diese Sache, die du am Anfang schon erwähnt hast, dass man irgendwie die...
Key Frames...
Genau, dass man weiß, wo die Key Frames sind.
Ja, ich glaube, dass das standardmäßig heute alle mitmachen. Das kann aber sein, dass...
Das steht dann aber sozusagen im Header, und der muss, also der sowohl muss es da drin stehen, als auch am Anfang. Das ist sozusagen eigentlich die Kurzfahrt.
Einige wir uns darauf.
Okay, gut, ja, ist ja auch mal schön, dass wir darüber gesprochen haben. Das heißt, man könnte einen Darwin-Streaming-Server nehmen, der funktioniert zumindest mit all dem gut, wo für Apple drauf steht. Das heißt, Spiel mit QuickTime ist aber im Prinzip eine Implementierung von offenen Standards. Zumindest, also nicht unbedingt von freien Standards, aber von offenen Standards. Das heißt, benutzt für den Transport RTP, RTSP, benutzt für Video, also MP4-Container und H264 für Video, AAC für Audio. Kann der auch MP3-Streaming machen? Keine Ahnung.
Ist da aber ein bisschen mit Kanonen auf Spatzen, aber kann er.
Okay, aber der macht dann MP3-Streaming über RTP, aber er macht nicht das Http-Streaming.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es eine aktuelle Version gibt, die das implementiert, aber die, die ich kenne, macht das noch nicht.
Dann gehen wir noch mal kurz zur Eiskasse. Jetzt können wir nämlich auch schön diesen Bogen zu Http finden. Also wir hatten ja bisher immer so dieses Streaming als aufwendiges Protokoll. Der Kleine kann jederzeit sagen, ach, mein Kunde möchte gerne irgendwie eine halbe Minute nach vorne springen. Gib mir doch mal.
Und gib mir nicht zu viel.
Und gib mir nicht zu viel. Dann ist das alles schön esoterisch feingetunt. Dann sendet er dann halt so schnell wie es geht rüber und kann auch irgendwie betraten, umschalten und so weiter. Das ist quasi so ein bisschen die eilegende Wollmilchsau. Das war auch, glaube ich, ein Problem bei diesem ganzen RTP-Universum, dass da einfach so viel von dem Client erwartet wird und natürlich damit auch von dem Server, dass es mit den Implementierungen immer so eine Sache war.
Vielleicht muss man an der Stelle noch ein Fass aufmachen. Und ich mache es auch ganz kurz, aber was dieses Streaming so attraktiv gemacht hat, das ist nämlich, dass ich auf einmal so eine Art Kontrolle darüber bekomme, wer sieht meinen Content, wie viel davon sieht er.
Die Sehgewohnheiten werden genau erfasst.
Die eine Möglichkeit, die ich bekomme, ist, ich kann sehr genau analysieren, wie lange gucken die, welche Teile gucken sie ab, wo springen sie ab. Ich kann auf der anderen Seite aber, auch jetzt, das ist ein großes Wort für wir, aber diese ganze DRM-Sache, ich kann in irgendeiner Art und Weise besser meine Rechte managen. Während sozusagen bei diesem Progressive Download, also bei YouTube ganz konkret, im Hintergrund, während ich mir so ein Video angucke, dass eine 1 zu 1 Kopie des Videos auf meiner Festplatte entsteht, passiert das beim Streaming halt nicht.
Was nicht heißt, dass man über einen Stream nicht den vollen Inhalt abgreifen könnte?
Ja, aber auch an der Stelle gibt es, also über einen normalen Stream, gibt es Software, die den Inhalt mit abgreifen, aber da gibt es jetzt noch zwei, oder mindestens zwei Sicherheitssysteme, um diese Streams etwas sicherer zu machen. Einmal gibt es ein Adobe-eigenes, proprietäres Protokoll und Windows selber unterstützt das halt auch. Also Windows schreibt ja diese DRMs selbst in die Dateien mit rein. Adobe hat die Möglichkeit, RTMPI heißt das dann eben, also Encrypted Streams durch die Republik zu jagen. Das ist ein eigener, proprietärer Standard, der meines Erachtens auch noch nicht geknackt ist. Das wäre mal was für euch. Um Filme eben zwischen Server und Client sicher hin und her zu bringen. Und es gibt eben mit diesen Flash Streaming-Servern auch die Möglichkeit, um da dieses Tor nochmal aufzumachen. Die meiste Software, die versucht, diese Flash Streams mitzuschneiden, bedient sich quasi zwei Tricks. Der erste ist, sich einfach auf die Netzwerkkarte zu setzen und die Pakete mit zu sniffen, die an mir vorbeifliegen. Sie am Ende wieder zusammenzusetzen und zu sagen, voila, ein Video. Das umgeben sie mit dieser RTMPE-Technologie, dass es halt verschlüsselte Pakete sind, die durch die Gegend fliegen. Das zweite, was sie machen, ist, man kann eben eine eigene RTMPE-Verbindung aufbauen, genauso wie man eine HTTPS-Verbindung aufbauen kann. Das heißt, sie setzen sich auf die Netzwerkkarte, gucken, mit welchem Server verbinde ich mich eigentlich gerade mit welchem Aufruf, machen das gleiche nochmal parallel dazu, also bauen einen zweiten Stream parallel auf und schneiden die dechiffrierten Pakete mit, die sie dort bekommen. Dort gibt es aber eben eine Sicherheit, ich kann es dann serverseitig einstellen, dass ich sage, dieser Client, der kriegt eben nur die Möglichkeit, diesen Stream einmal aufzubauen. Das kriegt halt einen speziellen Handshake. Und dieser Handshake ist das zweite Beispiel.
Okay, also Replay-Attacken, dass man das nicht anwenden kann.
Das heißt eben, sagen wir mal, das Spektrum der Möglichkeiten, meinen Content zu sichern vor der bösen Welt da draußen, ist mit diesen Streaming-Servern deutlich mehr gegeben, als es das mit irgendwelchen Download-Möglichkeiten ist.
Und damit das ist für manche Leute interessant. Nicht jeder Content ist jetzt unbedingt in Gefahr, mitgeschnitten zu werden. Es gibt ja auch viele Sachen, die in dem Moment sind, wo sie schon nicht mehr live sind, einfach nicht mehr interessant. Also der eigentliche Wert liegt sozusagen eher im Live als im Inhalt. Aber das ist natürlich für jeden anders. Ich grübel gerade ein bisschen.
Der Sprung zum HTTPS-Streaming.
Ja, ja, der Sprung zum HTTPS-Streaming. Ich wollte nur mal gucken, ob ich hier nochmal nachhacke. Icecast als die andere Lösung, die als Open-Source-Variante vorhanden ist. Da, Winx Streaming Server haben wir erwähnt.
Du bringst mich hier in Bedrängnis, sage ich.
Das ist meine Aufgabe hier. So, dann leg mal los. Ich weiß, du machst, glaube ich, nicht viel mit Icecast. Das ist nicht so dein Ding. Darum geht es immer auch erst mal gar nicht. Aber Icecast hat es ja populär gemacht, das, was man heute unter MP3-Streaming zu verstehen, überhaupt populär zu machen. Also wenn heute Streaming breitbandig eingesetzt wird, dann da. Und das ist eigentlich genau das, wo eben auch diese ganzen komplexen RTP-Gesachen überhaupt nicht herkommen. Eigentlich ist das ja ein Progressive-Download-Streaming. Eigentlich wird ja nichts anderes gemacht, als die mp3-Datei per HTTP zu übertragen. Oder?
Ich glaube, dass Audio-Streaming nicht einfach nur ein Download ist. Ich glaube, dass auch dort ein Protokoll stattfindet, was eine fortwährende Kommunikation zwischen zur Weise des ist.
Na klar, man kann sich ja jederzeit einklingen und kriegt halt immer das Aktuelle. Aber im Wesentlichen ist ja da nichts anderes drin, als ein MP3, so wie man es aus dem File lesen würde, kommt dann halt einfach über HTTP. Und ab dem Moment, wo man ihn anfordert, kriegt man halt das, was gerade aktuell ist. Das ist ja durch Icecast popularisiert worden. Das ist ja auch in iTunes eingebaut. Also mittlerweile irgendwie jedes nennenswerte Endgerät und jeder nennenswerte Medienplayer ist in der Lage, über HTTP MP3 zu empfangen. Und das reicht ja eigentlich auch schon vielen. Das hat ja im Prinzip diese ganze Internetradio-Geschichte popularisiert. Wir verwenden das ja hier auch. Chaosradio wird immer gestreamt. Da hat sich hier auch aus dem Hörerkreis eine eigene Initiative gebildet. Das kann man an dieser Stelle auch nochmal erwähnen. Xenim, das Xenim-Streaming-Network, die im Prinzip eine Kaskade von Icecasts haben, die dann auch automatisch die Last verteilen, was ganz pfiffig gelöst ist. Das heißt, wenn sich da irgendwie 100 Leute connecten, dann werden die dann eben auf mehrere Server, die sich eben dynamisch dazu verfügen gestellt haben, einfach round-robed verteilt, sodass das eben auch alles schon ganz gut händelbare Lösungen ist. Also für Audio ist das eigentlich der günstigste Weg. Und die anderen Methoden, was weiß ich, Flash oder so weiter, ist ja eigentlich vollkommen unattraktiv. Richtig überlegen, was man tut, muss man eigentlich erst in dem Moment, wo eben das Bild dazu kommt. Jetzt hast du gesagt, Icecast unterstützt auch Okteora als Streaming-Variante. Das heißt, macht da letztendlich auch nichts anderes. Verwendet der dann aber dann auch RTP? Ja, also okay. Das heißt, das ist dann sozusagen die erste Lösung, die wirklich so komplett auf freien Standards aufsetzt. Sowohl dem Protokoll, als auch eben dem Format, dem Encoding fürs Video in einem Org-Container. Also von da ist es sozusagen frei von vorne bis hinten. Das funktioniert auch gut. Hast du damit schon mal irgendwie rumgetestet?
Ich hab das einmal gesehen. Das funktioniert augenscheinlich. Man muss dazu sagen, dass dieser Teora-Video-Standard halt erst total toll, weil er frei ist. Die Ergebnisse, die man damit erzielt, sind halt noch nicht auf dem Level, von dem, was H264 heute kam. Und da, und jetzt muss man noch einmal kurz zurückspulen. Bei der Frage, was für Kosten kommen auf mich zu, wenn ich eine Streaming-Plattform aufbaue. Nehmen wir an, ich habe vor 50.000 Leuten gleichzeitig ein hochqualitatives Bildsignal zu übertragen. Bei so einer Konstruktion fallen am Ende die Lizenzkosten für die Server gar nicht mehr so ins Gewicht, sondern das, was die eigentlich Kosten sind, die bei mir entstehen, sind die Treffekosten. Weil ich einfach so wahnsinnig viele Bits und Bytes durch die Republik pumpe. Und an der Stelle ist es für mich einfach ungünstig, wenn die Dateien bei gleicher Qualität größer werden müssen.
Aber wenn das jetzt nicht so das Problem ist, dann ist das zumindest eine Lösung, für die man keine Lizenzen zahlen muss. Und das ist ja auch schon mal ganz hilfreich. Also, wenn man sozusagen jetzt nicht wirklich... Also man kann ja darüber auch verschiedene Bitraten anbieten. Nehm ich mal an. Also von daher, man kann sich schon sozusagen anpassen an das, was man hat. Man hat dann bloß vielleicht im direkten Vergleich etwas weniger Qualität. Kann dann sagen, ok, dann setzt man einfach ein bisschen mehr Bitrate voraus. Dann kann man das damit wieder irgendwie ausgleichen. Und ansonsten haben wir auch eine Menge Geld gespart, weil wir eben die ganzen Software-Kram eben so kriegen.
Genau. Ich meine, wir können die Liste ja einmal durchgehen. Was würde ich heute machen? Ich habe eine Kamera oder lassen wir das Mikrofon mal weg. Ich habe eine Kamera, ich habe ein interessantes Bild und ich möchte... Nein?
Doch, doch, ist eine super Idee. Ich wollte jetzt bloß dieses Ganze, was machen denn die Firmen eigentlich tatsächlich so real? Noch mal kurz abschließen, weil wir haben jetzt viel über Flash geredet, wir haben über freie Lösungen geredet, wir haben über Reel geredet, aber wir haben noch nicht über Microsoft so viel geredet. Weil Microsoft ist ja auch immer so, dass sie alle drei Jahre eine neue Strategie verfolgen. Was haben die denn eigentlich so abgefackelt über die Zeit? Danach bauen wir uns einen eigenen Server irgendwie.
Also, Microsoft hat ein sehr guten, proprietären, eigenen Video- Encoder geschrieben. Microsoft schafft es auch mit Windows Media, seit Windows Media 9, glaube ich, Videos in hoher Qualität sehr klein zu kriegen.
Also ist das, was man als WMV kennt, bzw. was Sie dann als VC1 Standard versucht haben, uns allen unter zu jubeln, bis dann irgendwie die HD, DVD komplett über den Teich gegangen ist und jetzt redet da Gott sei Dank kein Mensch mehr drüber.
Es gibt dazu eine quelloffene, aber dennoch umsonst Software, um mir diese Videos selber zu erstellen, wenn ich noch auf dem Laufenden bin. Der Windows Media mit dem Live-Encoder gibt es eins, wo man die Live-Signale...
Wie von Microsoft? Quelloffen?
Ne, nicht quelloffen. Die Augen hättet ihr sehen.
Ich weiß nicht. Ne, ist ja nicht so, dass sie nicht hier und da schon mal so ein paar Open-Source-Tools tatsächlich rausgetan haben. Ich befalle jetzt gerade nicht ein, was es war. Deswegen wäre ich jetzt nicht zu überrascht gewesen. Okay, wie auch immer.
Und es gibt dazu eben einen proprietären Streaming-Server, der Geld kostet. Von daher ist es das gleiche Paket wie der anderen Sachen. Ich glaube, wir haben es nicht in dem Sinne aus bösen Willen gerade außen vorgehalten, sondern weil quasi das Geschäftsmodell das Gleiche ist, was an anderer Stelle geschieht. Ich habe einen Video-Standard, der eben auf Microsoft-PCs sehr gut funktioniert, der aber eben in der Welt sonst Probleme bereitet. Das muss man einfach ganz klar dazu sagen. Und ich habe einen Streaming-Server, den ich für Geld lizenzieren kann. Und meines Wissens, aber da bewege ich mich auf Glatteis, gibt es noch keinen reverse-ingenierten, aber da eier ich. Es würde mich nicht wundern, einen zu finden.
MMS ist ja nun als Protokoll, dann eben auch WMV als Übertragung, leider sehr verbreitet, insbesondere hier in unserer öffentlich-rechtlichen Landschaft. Wenn man sich diese ganzen Media-Theken von ZDF und so weiter anschaut, die haben dann zwar auch so verschiedene Möglichkeiten. Ich bin zum Einzelnen nicht so ganz darüber informiert, was die alles machen, aber sie machen mittlerweile auch Flash und sie machen eben auch immer MMS. Warum auch immer. Vielleicht performt es besser auf Windows. Kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, weil dieses Flash ist ja eigentlich furchtbar langsam. Zumindest ist es auf Mac unerträglich. Hat immer diesen schönen Nebeneffekt, dass man diese eigentlich nur per Streaming bereitgestellten Dateien in der Media-Thek ganz ordentlich mitschneiden kann, weil das funktioniert ganz gut mit M-Player. Das, was Sie kennen, den Trick, nicht wahr? Dumpstream, also WMV mitschneiden über das MMS-Protokoll. Das ist etwas, was heute noch ganz gut funktioniert, wenn man sich den M-Player zusammenkompiliert. Und dann gibt es zumindest mal eine Möglichkeit, diese bekloppterweise eben nicht als Progressive-Download angebotenen Dateien auch ordentlich zu archivieren, wie sich das gehört.
Auch da muss man aber dazusagen, ich bin da nicht sehr firm, aber ich bin mir sicher, Windows Media bringt ein sehr ausgefuchstes, eigenes Digital Rights Management System mit. Das ist ja das, womit sie eigentlich das Geld verdienen wollen.
Ja gut, aber das wird jetzt bei den öffentlich-rechtlichen Mechaniken nicht eingesetzt. Also könnten, aber naja, dann gut.
Dazu muss man ja auch sagen, dass die öffentlich-rechtlichen in irgendeiner Art und Weise ja einen gebührenfinanzierten Auftrag haben, ihr Material auch frei zur Verfügung zu stellen. Das heißt, die Frage, ob diese Filme denn nur mit DRM-Versehen so viel Sinn machen würden, da muss man natürlich auch noch mal stellen.
Gut, jetzt haben wir also viele Protokolle. Also was ist das, was man zu Microsoft eigentlich sagen kann? Im Wesentlichen, so wie Sie machen WMV Version 9 und Sie machen MMS und das sind irgendwie Ihre Produktpalette und Sie haben irgendwie einen eigenen Streaming-Server, den kann man irgendwie bezahlen, wie andere auch und frei gibt es nichts. Das heißt, eigentlich ist es auch eine relativ unattraktive Geschichte, es sei denn, man hat wieder zu viel Geld und will sowieso nur irgendwie auf Windows schicken, wenn man ein bisschen mehr groß Plattform sein will, dann geht man schon besser auf Flash, wird aber genauso viel Geld los. Diesmal zahlt man es bloß an jemand anders. Oder man sagt irgendwie, ich setze jetzt mal auf Standards, wo es dann so bei dem Kleinen ein bisschen wacky wird, mit dem Darwin Streaming Server, das funktioniert auf Macs ganz gut, bei Windows kann ich es gerade selber nicht so richtig beurteilen und dann dient es auch nicht. Oder man geht eben komplett in den Open Source-Wake und sagt, ok, hier Okteora, irgendwie alles nur...
Ich pfeife auf Zuschauer.
Ja, oder sagen wir mal, ich kenne meine Zielgruppe. Das kann ja auch durchaus passen. Dafür ist es aber die reine Lehre und spermerfreies Streaming sozusagen. So, wir spulen nach vorne. Und wir kommen auch gleich noch auf diesen, ich baue mir meinen eigenen Server, aber jetzt müssen wir ja sozusagen diesen HTTP-Aspekt nochmal einbringen.
Was passiert jetzt?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wer da wirklich mit angefangen hat. Ich wollte vorhin diesen Bogen schlagen über dieses HTTP-MP3-Streaming. Das ging jetzt ein bisschen nach hinten los. Tatsache ist, es gibt jetzt die Bewegung, RTP fallen zu lassen wie eine heiße Kartoffel, weil es dann am Ende des Tages eben doch immer zu viel Ärger ist mit den ganzen Firewalls. Und man sagt einfach, das einzige Protokoll, was im Internet problemlos funktioniert, ist HTTP. Da ist was dran. Das ist schade, aber da ist was dran. Und wir haben jetzt eigentlich so schnelle Netze, dass wir uns den Overhead, der in so einem HTTP-Request drinsteckt, eigentlich nicht weiter beunruhigen müssen. Wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, ist es ja jetzt so, dass man sagt, wir teilen jetzt einfach die Videodatei in Häppchen auf. Und der Client holt sie sich einfach in Häppchen. Da wird dann etwas mehr unter Umständen geschickt, als benötigt wird. Aber das ist einfach mal insgesamt ein geringeres Problem als das, wenn man es so bitgenau machen will wie ATP. Hab ich das richtig verstanden?
Also ich glaube, dass unter diesem ominösen Wort HTTP-Streaming heute schon wieder viele verschiedene Sachen verstanden werden.
Ja, aber vom Konzept her sind sie glaube ich alle vergleichbar.
Das eine ist das, was Apple gerade implementiert hat. Und zwar auf das iPhone und auf Mac OS X, Snow Leopard kam es jetzt mit. Das ist eigentlich ein kleinzeitiges Feature gewesen, was dort deployed wurde. Das kleinseitige Feature ermöglicht es mir eben beispielsweise mit meinem iPhone, wenn ich auf eine MP4-Datei linke, die auf meinem iPhone wiedergegeben werden kann, also Base Profile oder was man alles noch dabei beachten muss. Und es darf auf der X- und Y-Achse nicht zu groß werden. Dann kann ich mit meinem iPhone einfach zu einer anderen Stelle des Films hinspringen. Und zwar auch zu einer Stelle, die noch nicht heruntergeladen wurde. Das heißt, den Hazzle, den man davor versucht hat, mit einem Lighty serverseitig zu lösen, dieses ganze Problem, das muss ich die Datei neu zusammenstellen und ab jetzt tue ich es so, als wäre ich. Und den Hatter sage ich auch als erstes nochmal. Viel Komplexität ist auf einmal in den Client gelandet. Das heißt, mein Client kann einfach an einen Webserver, das kann standardmäßig der Apache und der Lighty und alle können das, dass ich einfach bei einer großen Datei sage, ich möchte aber die Bytes jetzt erst ab der Mitte bekommen. So ein Request kann ich einfach machen.
Der Client rechnet sich sozusagen selber aus, wo er hin muss.
Der Client sagt einfach, gib mir mal zuerst den Hatter und der ist inzwischen sogar so schlau, dass er zuerst sagt, gib mir mal die ersten drei Bytes oder so, da schaue ich rein, ob das der Hatter ist. Wenn es das nicht ist, fragt er den Server, gib mir mal die letzten Bytes. Das heißt auf einmal ist wahnsinnig viel, diese Probleme, die wir gerade am Anfang besprochen haben, Server-seitig zu lösen, werden hier klein- seitig.
Aber trotzdem erlaubt ja dieses Hin und Her, also diese Definition des HTTP-Streaming-Protokolls, funktioniert so. Also einerseits ist es so ein bisschen wie MP3-Streaming, also sie benutzen zum Beispiel dasselbe Playlist-Format, also zumindest jetzt in der Apple-Variante. Andererseits gibt es ja auch die Möglichkeit, Bitrate-Negotiation zu machen, also man kann schon sagen, irgendwie so das letzte, das kam mir ein bisschen zu langsam, schick mir mal die nächsten fünf Sekunden in einer niedrigeren Bitrate. Also das ist schon Teil der ganzen Sache. Und da muss man ja schon auch einen Server haben, der das auch beantworten und bedienen kann.
Genau, jetzt kommt quasi das, der eigentliche Zauber, was sich die haben gerade darunter vorstellen. Das ist nämlich, dass dieses RTTP-Streaming, ganz einfach ausgedrückt, ungefähr wie folgt, funktioniert. Ich nehme meine fertige Datei, die schneide ich mir in handliche Häppchen. Das ist sogar nicht fest definiert, ich darf mir das selber aussuchen. Ich glaube, so fünf Sekunden sind so ein typisches Häppchen, ne? Genau. Das ist, glaube ich, heute noch nicht entschieden. Ich habe eine Implementation gesehen, wo man die Datei tatsächlich am Anfang in diese Häppchen physisch zerschneidet, sodass sehr viele kleine Dateien bei mir an der Platte liegen. Auf jeden Fall wird parallel dazu eine Playlist, die heißt dann auch P-List-Datei erstellt. Ich glaube, sie heißt P-List oder vielleicht gibt es beide Implementationen. Ich habe eine gefunden, wo am Ende tatsächlich Punkt P-List stand.
Das ist wahrscheinlich beim Darwin-Streaming-Server, bei Apple werden ja immer solche Konfigurationsdateien in P-List abgespeichert.
Auf jeden Fall steht in dieser Datei nichts anderes drin als ein Index dieser vielen hundert Schnipsel, die ich davor erzeugt habe. Ab dann kann man sich ja ungefähr vorstellen, wie die Kommunikation zwischen kleinen Server funktioniert. Das heißt, der Kleine merkt, das sind 5-Sekunden-Häppchen. Dann nehme ich mal die ersten beiden. Und wenn ich den ersten abgefeuert habe, frage ich mal nach dem dritten. Das heißt, ich kann immer in dieser Playlist nachschauen, wo bin ich gerade, was ist das nächste, was ich brauche.
Das heißt, die Playlist ist eher so eine Art Menü von irgendwie Datei-Schnipseln, wo sich dann der Kleine das passende aussuchen kann.
Genau.
Das heißt, das Wunder liegt eher da drin, diese Playlist-Datei zu generieren.
Als ich das gelesen hatte, hatte ich das Gefühl, selbst wenn es ein Tool gibt, was das für mich automatisiert macht, möchte ich eigentlich nirgendwo auf meinem Server Ordner drin haben, wo Tausende von 5-Sekunden-Schnipseln mit UU-IDs oder so. Das fühlt sich erstmal nicht toll an. Trotzdem ist natürlich, bei dieser Art und Weise fortzugehen, es ist ja überhaupt gar nicht gesagt, dass ich das im Vorwege machen muss. Das heißt, ich habe es bis jetzt noch nicht gefunden, aber es ist natürlich total denkbar, dass so etwas serverseitig auch in Echtzeit geschieht. Diese Playlist kann ich ja auch, ist ja ein leichtes für einen modernen CPU, das mal ebenso zu berechnen, wie die Datei-Habchen aussehen müssten und so zu tun im Fallsystem, als lägen diese Dateien dort. Da ist, glaube ich, das letzte Wort noch nicht gesprochen, wie dieser Standard-Präsident.
Aber ich glaube, die eigentliche Idee ist, dass, wenn man diese Schnipsel-Methode nimmt, kann ich jeden Server verwenden. Genau, das heißt, ich brauche überhaupt keinen speziellen Streaming-Server mehr, sondern ich brauche eigentlich nur einmal eine Software, die mir alles so aufbereitet, dass ich jeden beliebigen, normalen Apache nehmen kann. Und dann kommt einfach dieser Client, also der im iPhone eingebaut ist und auch bei Mac OS X eingebaut ist und der vielleicht auch jetzt keine Ahnung, ob der noch andere Deployment erfahren wird, das wird sich zeigen. Und der greift dann einfach erstmal auf diese PLS-Datei zu. Also die Playlist kriegt irgendwie quasi das Menü. Die liegt da auch einfach nur so stumm rum. Also für fertige Videos ist das ja alles kein Problem. Und dann selektiert er sich eben die Häppchen, die er eben haben will und gut ist. Das heißt, komplett ohne Streaming-Server kann ich beliebig viele Clients bedienen. Also ich habe da keine Lizenzsperre oder so, mit irgendwie mehr als zehn Schauen dir zu. Jetzt müssen wir Geld überweisen. Das ist ja genau das, was man unter... Also nicht nur das, aber auch das will man auf jeden Fall vermeiden. Und wenn man halt einen spezialisierten Server hat, der zwar HTTP-Streaming macht, aber eben auch genau weiß, was er tut, dann braucht man unter Umständen, die Dateien nicht vorher aufzubereiten, wie du gerade malest, bzw. kann auch Live-Bilder senden.
Genau. Das gibt es auch schon als Implementation, wie man quasi Livestreams über HTTP-Streaming nach außen tut. Wir haben das selber bei dieser Bundesradiosendung noch mit so einer Agli-Bita gemacht, aber auch da gab es auch ein bisschen von dem iPhone. Genau. Auf dem iPhone eben über einen HTTP-Stream, Port 80, einfach ein Livesignal des Videobildes zu bekommen.
Genau. Apple war ja nicht die Ersten, ich glaube, die Ersten, die so was gemacht haben, waren Microsoft tatsächlich. Die haben schon vor ein, zwei Jahren oder so schon auch mal versucht, so eine ähnliche Spezifikation zu machen. Allerdings war da, glaube ich, noch irgendwie nur mit halt nur mit Windows Media und lalala, also die üblichen Beschränkungen. Wollte dann keiner haben. Jetzt habe ich gehört, hast du, glaube ich, auch gehört, dass Adobe auch wieder so was Ähnliches ansteuert. Die Frage, ob die da jetzt auf den Apple-Weg einschwenken oder nicht.
Also Adobe hat zwei interessante Sachen angekündigt. Das war, glaube ich, in der gleichen Pressemitteilung. Das Erste war, dass sie den Flash Player 10 soll deren jetzige Flash Lite Version ersetzen und endlich auf die mobilen Geräte kommen. Mit H.264-Unterstützung und allem.
Ja, sie haben versprochen, dass er jetzt auch mal schnell läuft.
Und das Zweite, was sie dabei ominös in so einem Nebensatz angekündigt haben, ist, dass der auch HTTP-Streaming dann unterstützen würde. Wobei nicht klar, also das ist ja so ein tolles Wort. Ich glaube, es weiß noch keiner. Meines Erachtens gibt es noch keine Tech-Spec, von was Adobe davor hat zu unterstützen, sondern sie haben einfach mal so ein Buzzword in die Welt hinaus geworfen.
Ich vermute mal, dass sie sich gar nicht erlauben können, dann nicht mit dem iPhone kompatibel zu sein. Ich meine, wenn ihr Business in dem Bereich im Wesentlichen das Verkaufen von Streaming-Servern ist, dann kann ihnen der Kleine ja dann auch irgendwann ein bisschen egal sein, wenn sie dann auch beim Dateiformat damit reingehen. Das heißt, es kann sein, dass sich da tatsächlich ein neuer Standard abzeichnet, der tatsächlich Verbreitung findet. Wie stellst du das ein?
Also, ich bin da, sagen wir mal, noch etwas verhalten. Ich sehe im Moment relativ viele Nachteile davon. Ich verstehe den Grundgedanken zu sagen, wir müssen hier mal auf offene Standards setzen. Und ich verstehe auch den Grundgedanken zu sagen, das kann doch nicht sein, heute sind dieses multimediale Internet sowas, das ist ja allgemein gut einfach geworden. Das ist wichtig, dass das Internet für jeden da draußen nicht nur aus Bleiwüsten besteht, sondern dass es mit Bild und Ton angereichert ist. Also sind diese Streaming-Server einfach immanent wichtig geworden. Deshalb ist es wichtig, dass es freie Implementationen davon gibt, die für jedermann zugänglich sind. Das ist die eine Seite. Die zweite Seite ist, und das ist ja die Ecke, aus der ich so herkomme, jetzt werfen wir mal 100.000 Euro gegen eine Serverinfrastruktur und gucken mal, was hinten dabei herauskommt. Und da ist mir noch nicht ganz klar, dass das ein Problem ist. Ich habe auf einmal einen Web-Server, wo ich, ja, es stimmt, ich kann jeden normalen Web-Server dafür verwenden. Und kann in dieser Art der Konfiguration viele kleine Video- oder Audioschnipsel und so eine PLS-Datei in ein Verzeichnis legen und der Kleine kann das abfragen. PLS-Datei. Please read me first. Das Zweite, was dabei natürlich entsteht, ist, dieser Server wird im Gegensatz zu davor mit wahnsinnig vielen Requests bombardiert werden. Weil die Clients alle fünf Sekunden, und fünf Sekunden Happien sind ja schon relativ lang, vielleicht wird man wegen des Ansprechverhältnisses sogar zu noch kürzeren Schnipseln übergehen. Das heißt, einfach der Client macht viele, viele Requests auf diesen Web-Server, was sie im Zweifelsfall auch früher in die Knie zwingen wird. Das ist auf jeden Fall ein Problem des Lastmanagements, wie die Web-Server mit diesen vielen, vielen Requests. Das nächste Problem, was ich heute noch nicht wirklich gelöst sehe, ist, dass man praktisch alle Statistiktools, die man davor klassischerweise bei Web-Servern so verwendet hat, danach eigentlich in die Tonne treten kann. Weil da liegen irgendwelche komisch benannten kleinen Schnipsel-Dateien bei mir rum. Auf die werden wahnsinnig viele Requests gefeuert.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, wenn wir mal von einer Stunde Video ausgehen und wir schnipseln die jetzt mal in, bleiben wir mal bei dem Beispiel, 5 Sekunden Häppchen. Was haben wir dann? 60 Minuten, 60 Sekunden, so durch 5, 720. Ich meine 720 HTTP-Requests über eine Stunde verteilt, ist ja jetzt nicht so viel.
Ne, pro User, aber ja.
Ja gut, pro User, aber auch wenn ich das irgendwie mal 100 nehme. Also das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie außerhalb von, ne? So andererseits weiß ich ja dann sozusagen auch, welche Häppchen geladen wurden. Das ist ja dann durchaus einfach auch zuzuordnen, weil ja jede URL eindeutig genau sagt, in welcher Bitrate, welcher Teil des Films, wann, wo, von welchem User, la la la, IP-Adresse. Also die mag es vielleicht noch nicht geben, die Tools, aber auf der anderen Seite ist es relativ einfach, dann aus dem normalen Apache-Log-Fall so eine Statistik auch zusammenzubauen. Wahrscheinlich sogar noch einfacher als das jetzt bei RTP möglich ist.
Das ist tatsächlich auch ein Drama.
Genau, das ist nämlich auch ein Drama. Also da werde ich jetzt nicht so skeptisch, auch wenn ich natürlich generell verstehe, dass du da skeptisch bist, weil das ist definitiv ein Bereich, wo es in den letzten 15 Jahren sehr angemessen gewesen ist, immer skeptisch zu bleiben.
Und das letzte Problem tatsächlich, auch um das nochmal zu sagen, ist, dass diese Header-Information und diese PLS-Datei, also diese Playlist ist ja auch letztendlich eine Header-Information, wenn man mal so tun will, ein Talk, ein Index, dass diese bei großen Dateien sehr groß werden. Heute leben wir ja noch in so einer Welt, wo das Durchschnitts-YouTube-Video ist, glaube ich, so drei Minuten lang. Das sind alles Sachen, wo ich sage, okay, das heißt, die Gesamtdatei ist zweistellig, Megabyte, 20, 30, was auch immer, Megabyte groß. Davon macht der Header halt mehr oder minder einen Witz aus. Wir kommen heute in so Regionen, wo man sagt, eine halbe Stunde oder eine Stunde gut codiertes H264-Video, da hat man auf einmal 3, 4, 500 Kilobyte Header-Informationen, die man mit sich herumschleppt. Das heißt, in diesem Streaming-Kontext, wenn auf einmal gesagt wird, okay, du musst dir halt zuerst den Header herunterladen, bevor du das erste Videobyte wiedergeben kannst, bin ich auf einmal in so einer Problematik drin, ich brauche ein halbes Megabyte Informationen, bevor ich sinnvoll den ersten Schnipsel wiedergeben kann. Und ich habe das halt in so der ersten iPhone-Implementation gesehen, wo genau das das Problem ist. Ich habe eben sehr lange Dateien, die kann ich in hoher Qualität und Teil senden. Das funktioniert super, aber bei langen Dateien habe ich das Problem, Time to First Frame, das ich sehe, ist einfach sehr lang. Also weil doch 300 Kilobyte runterladen, das dauert dann halt doch ein bisschen.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, das Video, was dann später kommt, das ist ja noch nicht klein. Es fängt vielleicht spät an, aber es geht immerhin los. Ich verstehe deinen Einwand.
Genau, die Frage ist ja zurückgespult. Also, die HTTP-Streaming scheint ja ein Ansatz zu sein, wie Otto Normalbürger sehr einfach auf seiner handelsüblichen Webserver-Infrastruktur Videos ausliefern kann. Wobei er eben auf seinem Apache oder Lighty oder was auch immer er da hat, die Livestreaming-Lösung sicherlich mal in nächsten Jahren noch nicht einfach so implementiert haben wird, sondern er kann eben On-Demand-Videos, nachdem er sie speziell behandelt hat, ausliefern. Und da ist natürlich aus heutiger Sicht die Frage, was ist der Otto Normalbürger-Benefit dieses Vorgehens im Gegensatz zu so einer Lightie-Vorgehen, wie es heute herrscht, dem, was YouTube macht, und CoKG? Jetzt kannst du sagen, er möchte seinen Lightie nicht selber kompilieren und dann werde ich dir wahrscheinlich Recht geben. Und eventuell wird es auch bald ein Tool geben, wo sich der Normalbürger nicht damit rumschlagen muss, dass er auf einmal 700 Schnipseldateien per Hand auf einen FTP-Order ziehen muss oder sowas. Aber bislang ist es für mich, ich finde es einen interessanten Ansatz. Ich finde, ich habe ein bisschen den Verdacht, dass der Ansatz gepusht wird eigentlich von den heutigen Content-Delivery-Networks, also von Akamai und Co.KG, weil die tatsächlich in so einer Problemsituation sind. Die haben ja quasi weltweit wahnsinnig viele Server rumstehen, die quasi darauf aufgebaut sind, statischen Content irgendwie an ihre Edge-Locations zu kaschen. Das heißt, die haben irgendwo in der Mitte Burgen stehen, wo sehr viel Content rumliegt. Und um diese Burgen drum herum bauen sie sich Hunderte kleine Edge-Server. Und wenn ich eben meine Anfrage von gib mir diese Datei, gib mir die Startseite einer großen deutschen Homepage stelle, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit sehr hoch, dass ich auf so einem Content-Delivery-Network treffe, was mir diese Datei an einem Server bei mir um die Ecke casht. Diese Infrastruktur besteht seit den 90ern. Da sind, wenn nicht mal, sogar Milliarden reingeflossen.
Und die sind auch immer noch weiter.
Und siehe da, diese Infrastruktur ist quasi perfekt dafür geschaffen, dieses neue HTTP-Streaming auszuliefern.
Also alles, was nicht live ist, kann sozusagen wunderbar gecasht werden.
Genau. Das heißt, auf einmal funktionieren diese ganzen Mechanismen, die davor, die hatten echtes Rechtfertigungsproblem, weil die praktisch die Welt zugemüllt haben mit Proxies. Die haben sozusagen das Internet kaputt gemacht, weil sie an jeder Ecke ein Proxy geworfen haben. Und auf einmal kommt das Echtzeit-Internet um die Ecke. Kommt Twitter, bla bla bla, Streaming und dieser ganze Mist. Die müssen sich in Kellern gegenüber gesessen haben und gesagt haben, oh Gott, oh Gott, was machen wir denn da? Und siehe da, gehypt wird sozusagen der quelloffene Standard, der auf einer Lösung wirklich perfekt noch funktioniert. Und das sind Proxies. Oder also Proxy als Wort, was für diese...
HTTP Caching als Strategie.
Und ich weiß halt nicht, ich habe so den Eindruck, heute in der Diskussion wird halt so getan, als ob dieses Verfahren für normale, ich möchte Videos auf meinem Blog zeigen Menschen ein toller Vorteil wäre. Und ich finde, bei all dem, was ich bis heute lese, was man so tun muss, bis das funktioniert und was man mitbringen muss, sehe ich den Vorteil eigentlich noch gar nicht. Wahrscheinlich hat die Familie, die die Videos von ihrem Kind im Blog zeigen wollen, wahrscheinlich ist für die heute immer noch die beste Strategie, einfach das als Progressive-Download auf den Server zu legen oder auf YouTube oder auf Flickr oder hast du nicht gesehen. Also das heißt, da gibt es 100 Wege, wo man sagt, ach, mach das doch, hab da keinen Ärger damit. Und für, naja, genau, das war so meine Verspülungstheorie.
Ne, das muss ich zugeben, habe ich selber noch gar nicht drüber nachgedacht und macht total Sinn. Also das heißt natürlich dann auch sozusagen, das Caching ermöglicht von etwas, was aber tatsächlich gestreamt wird. Und das ist nicht unerheblich. Und vor allem, ich weiß nicht, gibt's denn schon irgendwie so ein einfaches Skript, was ich nehmen kann und dann schmeiße ich da irgendwie meine Videos drauf und dann kriege ich da so einen Datei-Bau mit den ganzen Schnipselchen?
Hab den Link nicht hier, aber ich habe mit wenig suchen einen FFmpeg-Skript gefunden, was das macht.
Das heißt, wenn man dann wirklich schon sowieso seine Videoerhelle hat, kann man die sich sozusagen dann einfach, gut, dann hat man alles nochmal doppelt, sozusagen, ja, also man hat so die Ursprungsdatei und dann jede nochmal, aber das ist ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch hinzunehmen, aber könnte dann im Prinzip out of the box mit einem ganz normalen HTTP-Server eben auch Streaming anbieten.
Genau.
Ist ja nicht doof.
Ja, ich bin gespannt, wo es hinführt. Also ich, mein persönliches Gefühl ist, dass die Verwaltung dieser Dateien irgendwie eine neue Handhabe braucht. Ja, also das heißt, aus heutiger Sicht sind diese selbst automatisierte Skripte, aber ich finde, es ist immer noch von so Menschen händelbar. Ich lade eine große Datei von A nach B, ich überprüfe am Ende, ob der MD5er stimmt, ob der Name noch gleich ist, ob die Berechtigungen stimmen und dufte. Auf einmal wird so ein Vorgang 1400 Requests schwer, von A nach B. Ich muss auffangen, was passiert, wenn so ein Schnipsel nicht mehr funktioniert? Was ist so? Ich muss in dieser ganzen, denken wir es mal dahin, in dieser ganzen HTTP-Cushing-Architektur. Ich muss auf einmal Logik implementieren. Was ist, wenn die Datei dort nicht vorliegt? Der Vorteil ist, glaube ich, dass diese Logik schon da ist bei den großen Anbietern. Das heißt, auf einmal bin ich natürlich, wenn ich über die ganze Welt verteilt 40.000 Cushing-Server habe und irgendjemand kommt um die Ecke mit so einer Idee, dann habe ich natürlich den enormen Vorteil, dass ich mir beispielsweise diese Frage der Lastverteilung überhaupt gar nicht mehr stellen muss. Das heißt, dieses System würde automatisch mitbringen, wenn ich ein einstündiges Video habe, aber von dem werden immer nur die ersten fünf Minuten geguckt, danach stellen alle auf. Da muss ich keine Logik implementieren, die das mitbringt, sondern das kann das System aus sich selber heraus schon, weil die angefragten Dateien halt mehr verteilt werden. Also meines Erachtens ist es eher eine Idee, die dafür taugt, sehr großen Broadcaster, die in diesen Http-Cushing-Architekturen arbeiten, dort die Treffekosten zu minimieren. Weil natürlich so ein Player, jetzt nehmen wir mal YouTube heute. Und darauf wette ich, das Hauptproblem von YouTube ist, dass sie wahnsinnig viel Video übertragen, das nicht geguckt wird. Das YouTube-Problem ist, die Leute gucken den Anfang, ich weiß nicht, wie viele echte und es gibt ja immer ein paar Zahlen, wie viele Milliarden und hast du nicht gesehen. Aber so richtig offiziell verlautbarte Zahlen gibt es ja noch nicht. Aber der gesunde Menschenverstand sagt einem ja, das Durchschnitts-YouTube-Video wird nicht bis zum Ende geguckt. Es wird aber irgendwie bis zum Ende übertragen. Also ist deren Problem, die Zahlen für übertragene Bites, die nicht geguckt werden. Und das ist sinnloser Treffek. Das heißt, eigentlich haben die ein großes Interesse daran, ihre viele Tausend-Server-Infrastruktur auf so ein System umzustellen.
Ja gut, ich meine, das Interesse hat natürlich nicht nur die, bei denen würde es wahrscheinlich am meisten ausmachen, aber auch wer weniger zahlt, hat ein Interesse daran, noch weniger zu zahlen. An der Stelle passt es zusammen. Okay, gut, ich denke, das ist jetzt auch klar geworden, was HTTP-Streaming da für eine Verheißung ist. Die klassische RTSP-Geschichte mag, sagen wir mal, für überschaubare Delivery-Sachen und wo man auch den entsprechenden kleinen voraussetzen kann. Derzeit noch die einfachere Variante sein, aber es zeichnet sich ab, dass HTTP an der Stelle da schon was bedeutet. Jetzt haben wir natürlich nochmal diese H264-Problematik. Da würde mich auch mal interessieren, was du da darüber weißt. Ich habe schon mehrfach mal versucht, das zu recherchieren. Mir ist das ein bisschen unklar. Also kurz gesagt, der Vor- und der Nachteil von MPEG-4 ist, es handelt sich um einen Standard, der aus ganz viel Technologie, Wissen und damit natürlich auch verbunden ganz vielen Patenten zusammengestellt worden ist, um der Industrie eine Architektur zu präsentieren, wo zumindest mal klar ist, wie es aussieht. Das heißt, es ist nicht kostenlos, sondern es gibt in diesem Standard viele Dinge, die sind explizit kostenfrei und es gibt welche, die sind explizit Lizenzkosten behaftet, damit da die entsprechenden Patente mit abgedeckt werden von den Firmen, die das dort eingereicht haben. Das hat eben den Nachteil, dass nicht alles frei ist, aber es hat eben den Vorteil, dass man zumindest weiß, woran man ist. Und das ist ja auch der Grund, warum so Firmen wie Apple oder so sich eben auch massiv gegen jetzt Open-Source-Sachen da wehren. Nicht nur Apple, Nokia war da, glaube ich, auch mit dabei. Du hast vorhin schon angesprochen, es gab ja diese ganze Debatte, kam ja noch mal auf im Rahmen der derzeit stattfindenden Standardisierung Audio- und Videopräsentation auf Webseiten im HTML5-Standard. Da gibt es ja jetzt ein Audio- und Videotec, und es wurde viel darüber diskutiert, inwieweit man denn definieren sollte, was denn nun dann hinter dann da auch ist. Also auch mal sozusagen auf die Inhalte kommt und nicht nur darauf, wie man darauf verweist. Soweit ich weiß, ist es da jetzt stecken geblieben, dass sich eigentlich HTML5 selber um den Content-Typ nicht kümmert. Das heißt, man kann zwar sagen, da ist Video, man kann auf das eine oder andere verweisen, auch auf mehrere Sachen mit Fallbacks, aber das schafft insofern jetzt keine Klarheit, was man verwenden soll. Jetzt könnte man natürlich sagen, ok, jetzt haben wir hier den Standard, und es gibt da irgendwie das Baseline-Profile, das ist doch kostenlos, was wollt ihr denn alle? Aber ganz einfach ist es nicht. Sondern es gibt Klauseln in diesem ganzen MPEG4, Lizenzkram, die jetzt auch gerade im Jahre 2010 nochmal eine neue Schärfe annehmen. Also da ändert sich sozusagen was, was vorher so war. Und was ich weiß, hat es explizit mit Streaming zu tun und eben mit wie vielen Leuten man da irgendwas delivert.
Genau.
Was steckt dahinter?
Ich bin wirklich kein Jurist, aber es läuft ungefähr auf Folgendes hinaus. Es gibt ein Software-Patent auf diese Art der Videokompression, auf MPEG-4, H264 eben. Die ist in den USA, wie ich glaube, unstrittig gültig. Und es gibt einfach Lizenzbedingungen, die mit der Verwendung dieses Videokodex einhergehen. Die kann man sich auf deren Seite anschauen. Das läuft irgendwie, ich glaube, für Non-Profit oder für private Zwecke.
Aber mit deren Seite meinst du jetzt diese MPEG-IV-Licensance, diese LA, diese Licensance Agreement Association?
Es gibt eine Seite des MPEG-IV-Konsortiums, da stecken viele Firmen mit drin. Und dort sind Lizenzbedingungen mit aufgelistet. Und es läuft ungefähr folgendes hinaus. Also es liest sich heute, finde ich, immer noch so, dass sie eigentlich das Geld verdienen wollen mit Leuten, die den Codec in ihrer Hardware implementieren. Das heißt, wenn ich heute einen DVD-Bluray, hast du nicht gesehen, Player baue, in dem ein Chip drin steckt, der MPEG-4 decodiert, dann wollen sie von denen einen Euro pro Gerät. Also das ist da aufgelistet. Ich habe es mir nie genau durchgelesen, weil ich nie vorhatte, DVD-Player zu bauen. Aber klar, wenn man das da einbauen will, dann muss man Geld dafür bezahlen. Sie verlangen aber eben auch Geld für die Verbreitung und die Codierung von Filmen. Und zwar ab einer bestimmten Zuschauerzahl und ab einer bestimmten kommerziellen Nutzung oder so. Ich habe die Klausel nicht im Kopf. Und das alles macht es sehr kompliziert, sagen wir mal, kleinere kommerzielle Ideen auf HZO64 zu haben. Ich weiß aber, dass das in Europa und in Deutschland mindestens mal umstritten ist, ob diese Software-Patente hier auch gelten. Also ich glaube, das ist so der Moment, wo man einen guten Anwalt konsultieren sollte. Aber ich glaube, dass die moderne Lesart ungefähr wie folgt ist. Wenn man das in den USA tut, sollte man sich schleunigst daran halten. Wenn man das nur in Deutschland tut, kann man zumindest einmal darüber nachdenken, ob diese Software-Patente hier gültig ist. Dann müsste man sich, glaube ich, einfach einmal informieren. Das ist jetzt der richtige Moment für einen Juristen. Trotzdem, selbst wenn man diesen Weg gehen will, hat man auf einmal dann natürlich diesen Krenenfuß des Geo-IP-Loggons, Leuten aus den USA nicht zulassen, die Videos hier zu sehen an der Hacke.
Also diese erste Lizenzphase läuft bis Ende 2010. Das heißt, die eigentliche Veränderung kommt sozusagen dann ab 2011. Das ist also jetzt noch ein paar Monate hin, wenn man das jetzt hier zeitnah auch hört, was wir jetzt hier gerade machen. Ich versuche hier gerade nochmal parallel ein bisschen Klarheit zu bekommen. Ich weiß aber auch, dass das umstritten ist. Also es gibt da auch noch richtig Kampf. Unter anderem habe ich gehört, ist wohl auch Apple da, ganz weit vorne, die MP4-Konsortien davon abzuhalten, das durchzufechten, weil sie da einfach ein Backlash sehen für das ganze Projekt. Das kann ja auch sehr gut sein. Ich kann mir das sehr gut vorstellen. Selbst wenn man nicht davon betroffen ist, allein dieses Damokless-Schwert mit, du machst jetzt irgendein Business und irgendwann kostet allein das Anbieten sozusagen Geld. Dein Erfolg führt irgendwann dazu, dass du Misserfolg hast, weil du einfach Leute ausbezahlen musst, die damit eigentlich gar nichts zu tun haben. Und das alles nur, weil du halt eben, also nur in Anführungsstrichen, deren sogenanntes Intellektuelle Property nutzt. Das ist einfach ein extrem schwieriger Bereich. Ich hab so ein bisschen den Eindruck, da ist das Gefecht noch nicht ganz ausgefochten. Das wird sich noch zeigen. Muss man aber auf jeden Fall im Blick behalten. Insbesondere dahingehend, dass natürlich die Open-Source-Szene, die Free Software-Szene im Besonderen, mit Teora zumindest eine Alternative noch in der Hand hält und über Firefox ja auch entsprechende Unterstützung erfährt. Also in Firefox kann sozusagen jetzt in den neuesten Versionen sowohl HTML5 und bringt aber auch gleich diese Videoabspielfähigkeit für auch Teora mit sich.
Jetzt kann man es ja vielleicht noch einmal kurz erklären, was da gerade geschieht mit diesem HTML5. Also der Witz ist, dass natürlich diese Hoch-, also diese Player, die in den letzten Jahren ausgeliefert wurden, der Windows-Media-Player, der Flash-Player, der Real-Player, der Quicktime-Player, jetzt habe ich bestimmt noch ein paar vergessen, aber all die standardisierten Player können ja nicht nur Ton und Bild wiedergeben, sondern die bringen ja eine Hölle an Funktionalitäten mit, was die alles noch implementiert haben. Und die meisten davon können sogar am Ende noch Webseiten darstellen. Also gerade der Flash-Player ist ja heute dafür da, dass der alles kann, außer Videos wiedergeben noch so. Und jetzt gibt es diesen intelligenten Ansatz zu sagen, Moment mal, es gibt den HTML-Standard, der kann Standard immanent. Heute zum Beispiel schon Bilder, JPEGs, GIF-Bilder, die meisten eben auch PMG. Nur Microsoft hat sich in irgendeiner Version da einmal quergelegt. Aber in Webseiten einbinden, das gehört zu diesem Standard mit dazu. Videos und Audiophiles, aber auf jeden Fall Videophiles, sind komplett aus diesem Standard rausgehalten worden. Das heißt, wenn ich ein Video auf einer Webseite wiedergeben will, dann schreibe ich im Code der Webseite nicht einfach nur hier Video, sondern ich muss sehr kompliziert sagen, öffne an dieser Stelle der Webseite eine andere Software außer meinem Browser, also zum Beispiel den Flash Player oder den Windows Player. Muss man derzeit machen. Und gebe dieser anderen Software folgende Parameter mit, nämlich öffne das Video anstelle Hüseldüsel an Position und so weiter. Und jetzt kommt eben HTML5, quasi der Nachfolger. Und HTML5 soll oder enthält einen Videotag. Das heißt, es bringt die Möglichkeit mit, Videos so in Webseiten einzubauen, wie ich heute Bilder in Webseiten einbaue, ohne dass sich noch eine andere Software außer dem Browser dabei ansprechen muss. Und das bringt eben erstmal diesen enormen Vorteil mit, dass ich einfach in meinem HTML-Programm oder wie auch immer Videos einbinden kann, ohne mir Sorgen, ob ich viele andere Sachen zu machen. Und jetzt ist aber das Drama gleich am Anfang geschehen, nämlich in diesem großen HTML5-Gedankenwolke, wo die Browser-Produzenten selber zusammensetzen, haben sie sich eben nicht einigen können, sondern wir haben heute wieder das Caudavelge Safari in der ersten Implementation unterstützt, eben H264. Firefox unterstützt eben nur Oktheora, weil sie sagen, diese H264-Nummer, das eiert, da haben wir Schiss mit, deshalb machen wir nur was anderes. Genau, das ist die Liste. Chrome macht beides, Internet Explorer macht gar nichts. Oder ich weiß nicht, ob sie WMV schon machen oder nicht. Also es wäre ihnen zuzumuten, aber wie auch immer. Also das ist auf jeden Fall das große Drama heute. Wiederum, für die Firma, die heute Broadcaster ist und sagt, Mensch, ich habe doch Lust einer zukunftsfähige, wie auch immer, Lösung mit meinem Stock. Bei mir im Keller stehen 5000 Kassetten, da sind tolle Filme drauf. Die möchte ich der Welt zeigen. Für die ist natürlich gerade eine Blase zerplatzt. Weil es heißt, wenn ich mich an diesen tollen Standard halten möchte, bedeutet das eben nicht nur, dass ich wie heute eh schon üblich die fünf Versionen in verschiedenen Qualitätsstufen und dann auch noch iPod, iPhone und hast du nicht gesehen, iTunes, Apple, jetzt nenne ich nur Äpfelchen. Aber das heißt, die Videokodex, die ich heute als Standard codieren muss, das ist ja auch schon ein ganzer Blumenstrauß. Das ist so das, was ich eh heute tue. Und jetzt kommt die Browser noch dazu und sagen, du brauchst das Ganze auch nochmal in Org und vielleicht auch nochmal an WMV, um diese Standard zu erfüllen. Das heißt, ich hoffe, dass sich da noch eine Änderung ergibt. Aber diese Vorstellung, dass dieser Videotag quasi damit zunichte gemacht wird, dass sich jedem Browser dort etwas anderes anbieten muss, das Schwert hängt auf jeden Fall gerade über der ganzen Veranstaltung.
Ja, also ich halte das generell für was Gutes mit dem HTML5. Weil immerhin hat man mal jetzt geklärt, wie auf der kleinen Seite das jetzt überhaupt auszusehen hat. In Anführungsstrichen nur das Video-Format selber ist sozusagen noch nicht geortet worden. Aber man wird halt jetzt, sagen wir mal, diese komplexen User-Interfaces, die derzeit nur mit Flash gehen, auch mit JavaScript machen können und so. Das erlaubt einfach auch eine Interaktion mit Content, von dem man jetzt auch nicht unbedingt immer wissen muss, wie er denn real vorliegt. Das ist ja auch schon mal ein Schritt in die richtige Richtung. Jetzt haben wir glaube ich auch schon eigentlich fast alles abgehandelt. Du hast vorhin aber auch noch mal so schön angesetzt, so dieses, wenn ich jetzt mal selber einen Streaming-Server aufsetzen will, was muss ich tun? Das wäre doch jetzt so für das Ende der Sendung nochmal ein ganz netter Ansatz. Was hast du denn da so für Tipps?
Also ich weiß nicht, ob das selber einen Streaming-Server aufsetzen jetzt wirklich der tolle Tipp ist.
Ja oder ich will was gestreamt bekommen und so.
Also die erste Frage ist, was mache ich, wenn ich eine Live-Sendung irgendwie von A nach B übertragen will oder wenn ich gerne so. Und ich glaube, da stellen sich erst mal zwei Fragen. Das erste ist, tue ich das innerhalb von einem Larn innerhalb von meiner Firma? Sollen das nur Leute, will ich eine Konferenz? Und ich will, dass das viele Leute innerhalb meines Netzwerkes sehen. Dann ist es sicherlich sinnvoll, auf einen der quelloffenen Streaming-Server zu setzen, die es da draußen gibt. Ich habe das selber schon mehrfach eingebunden mit dem QuickTime Streaming-Server oder der Darwin Streaming-Server, also mit der Open-Source-Variante davon. Das Tolle, wir sind heute noch nicht darauf eingegangen, weil es eigentlich im Internet, im World Wide Web kaum eine Rolle spielt, aber bei der Übertragung von multimedialen Inhalten gibt es zwei Standards. Der erste ist ein Unicast-Standard. Der läuft darauf hinaus, dass ein Server mit einem Klienten eine 1 zu 1-Verbindung aufbaut. Und wenn eben 100 Leute zugucken, gibt es 100 1 zu 1-Verbindungen. Parallel dazu ist ein Standard entwickelt worden, der heißt Multicast. Multicast funktioniert letztendlich wie eine Radioantenne heute funktionieren würde. Das heißt, ich stelle in der Mitte einen Sender auf, und wie viele Leute mir zuhören oder nicht, ist mir eigentlich wurscht. Es produziert bei mir aber keine Last. Um diesen Multicast-Standard zu erfüllen, müssen die Switches, die dazwischen hängen, bestimmten Anforderungen genügen und bestimmt konfiguriert sein. Das heißt, das taugt im Internet im Moment nicht. Ich kann nicht Multicast einfach meine Fernsehsendung streamen, und dann können alle das mitzugucken, ohne dass es Treffik verursacht. Innerhalb meines Firmennetzwerkes ist es aber sehr wahrscheinlich, dass die Switches, die da in der Mitte sind, Multicast-fähig sind.
Aber da hat man auch die wenigsten Bandbreitenprobleme.
Ja, aber das ist trotzdem... Also nimm mal an... Also einmal ist meine Erfahrung, dass man gerade in größeren Unternehmen heute doch ein enormes Bandbreitenproblem hat. Weil das... Doch oft noch Leute sind, die haben sich dann teilweise für Außendienststellen so 6 Megabit synchron DSL aufschwatzen lassen und zahlen dafür wahnsinnig viel Geld heute noch. Das zweite Problem ist, man will natürlich auch schnell hochqualitatives Video übertragen. Das heißt, natürlich ist man... Wenn man irgendwo eine HD-Kamera aufstellt und das live senden will, dann ist man schnell bei 4-5 Megabit H264 gedünst, was man durch die Republik tut.
Du sagst, es gibt Multicast, aber nutzbar ist es eigentlich nur im Laden oder zumindest in einem firmenübergreifenden Netzwerk, wie weit sich das noch mal abstecken will. Ich muss dazu sagen, Multicast ist jetzt keine Erfindung speziell für Streaming, sondern das ist etwas, was von Anfang an eigentlich im IP eingebaut war, also schon bei IPv4. Allerdings ist eine der großen Failures im Internet, weil das einfach nie wirklich jemals nennenswert Unterstützung erfahren hat, sodass man sagen könnte, ach, da nehme ich jetzt einfach Multicast, dann ist irgendwie mein Delivery-Problem gelöst. Sondern das stößt einfach an Wände, mehrere Mauern. Und das ist auch mit IPv6, weiß ich nicht, ob sich das ändern wird. Da fehlt mir jetzt auch gerade selber der Überblick. Aber du hast das sozusagen mit dem Darwin Streaming Server auch schon erfolgreich zum Einsatz gebracht.
Genau. Also das heißt, innerhalb eines Unternehmens, wenn ich die Switches selber kontrolliere, die da dazwischen hängen, dann ist Multicast eine total tolle Sache. In dem Moment, wo das Mein-Lahn-Netzwerk verlässt, kann ich das knicken heute. Also das funktioniert einfach nicht. Weil ich halt nicht alle Switche kenne, die auf dem Weg auf meiner Route zum Kleinen sind.
Aber technisch bedeutet das, wenn ich irgendwie zehn Zuschauer habe und ein Paket kommt von einer bestimmten Multicast-Adresse, dann weiß der Switch das. Und wenn jemand anders das auch empfangen will, dann nimmt er einfach die Kopie, die er schon hat.
Genau. Und das hat den enormen Vorteil, dass meine Mühle, die den Stream sendet, den halt nur einmal senden muss. Das heißt, ich muss bei einer Multicast-Verbreitung wahrscheinlich gar nicht so etwas wie einen Streaming-Server aufsetzen, sondern es reicht, man einer kleiern, den ich in mein Firmennetzwerk reinhänge und sage, alle dürfen zuschauen und dann können alle einfach...
Und alle sind auch synchron?
Alle sind synchron, genau. Oder Millisekunden versetzt, wenn die auf verschiedenen Switches hängen, aber genau. Also das ist eine tolle Lösung für sowas, da lohnt es sich, was selber aufzusetzen. Wenn ich eine Live-Quelle sonst einfach irgendwie im Internet hinausblasen will, ist wahrscheinlich die erste Anlaufstelle einer der Top 4 umsonst Livestream-Anbieter, wie sie gerade da sind. Das ist livestream.com, ehemals Mogulus. Das ist Ustream. Das ist, jetzt kannst du mir langsam mal helfen, du hast sie ja alle auch schon...
Das sind die ersten beiden, die mir auch jetzt eingefallen werden.
Dass es echt noch mehrere gibt, tut es gerade ein bisschen...
Können wir das nachreichen?
Es gibt wirklich viele davon, die funktionieren alle. Wie heißen die, die das von dem Modell? TelefonQuick oder so? QIK. Okay, wir reichen es nach.
Die machen auch richtig... Die haben ja auch so einen Streaming-Infrastruktur-Video-Stream. Ich habe es jetzt im Einzelnen nicht verfolgt.
Also, davon gibt es Firmen wie Sand am Meer. Die haben alle, wie sie da sind, Bezahl- und For-Free-Modelle. Wobei sich die For-Free-Modelle, glaube ich, durch die Bank weg versuchen werden zu finanzieren.
Haben die denn alle nur... Also, welche Möglichkeiten gibt es denn da, Video reinzuschaufeln? Kann ich das nur mit so einem Flash-Client machen? Oder kann ich da auch per RTSP, mit meinem darinem Streaming-Server, irgendwie was reinpusten?
Also, je nachdem. Das Problem, was der Flash-Client bringt, eine tolle Sache mit, dort ist das schon angedeutet. Ich kann nämlich mit einem sehr einfachen Befehl mir einfach die Video- und die Audioquelle des Rechners greppen und senden irgendwo hin. Das heißt, so in Flash so etwas wie ein Video-Chat-Programm zu schreiben, ist praktisch trivial, weil es das mitbringt. Das Problem ist, dass der Flash-Client kleinseitig nur die Möglichkeit, ich glaube bis heute, nur die Möglichkeit mitbringt, H263-Video zu kodieren. Das heißt, die Qualität, in der ich damit von A nach B komme, ist nicht so toll. Man kann das auf YouTube testen, das ist immer so ein bisschen versteckt, aber es gibt eine YouTube-Seite, wo ich meine Webkamera aufzeichnen darf. Also das heißt, es gibt eine YouTube-Seite, die mache ich auf, dann sehe ich mich selber im Spiegel, kann auf Rekord drücken und mich selber aufzeichnen. Dann hat man eine Vorstellung davon, was die Kompressionsqualität ist, die dieser Player im Moment selber mitliefert. Das heißt, da tue ich mir einen Gefallen, wenn ich einen anderen Standard oder einen anderen Übermittlungsweg zum Anbieter wähle. Derer gibt es mannigfaltig viele. Die meisten Streaming-Server bieten selber auch die Möglichkeit, einfach über ein standardisiertes RTP-Protokoll, wo wir am Anfang waren, eine Videoquelle dort einfach hochzuschießen und das dort einfach dann zu wandeln. Sonst gibt es halt für umsonst den QuickTime-Media-Broadcaster oder QuickTime-Broadcaster. Das ist ein umsonstool, was auf dem Mac funktioniert und sehr zuverlässig einen RTP-Stream fabrizieren kann, den ich, glaube ich, gegen alle genannten Anbieter werfen kann. Bei einem Stream weiß ich es, bei den anderen bin ich nicht sicher. Es gibt auch frei den Flash-Media-Live-Encoder, heißt er dann, glaube ich, von Adobe. Der läuft nur auf Windows-Rechner, nicht auf dem Mac, macht aber ein sehr gutes Signal, kann auch VP6 und H264-Live-Signale codieren. Und dann gibt es in so einer Preis-Liga bis zu 500 Euro, Dollar, Euro, Dollar, ist eine schöne Idee, semi-professionelle bis zu professioneller Software, wo ich dann auch schon so ein paar Quellen schalten kann. Teilweise bringen die Anbieter bei Livestream, weiß ich es zum Beispiel, dem Procaster mit, sondern ein eigenes Stück proprietäres Software, die das dann auch für einen macht. Genau, also das sind sozusagen da diese Welt. Es kostet dann immer schnell relativ viel Geld, wenn ich anfange, das kommerziell zu nutzen oder wenn ich eben werbefrei auf deren Seite werden will. Da bin ich dann auch schnell im Bereich, wo der Traffic viel Geld kostet. Aber wenn meine Anforderung einfach ist, ich bin hier auf einer Konferenz und ich möchte einfach mal, dass die Leute da draußen sehen können, was hier geschieht, ist das sicherlich der beste Weg. Wenn ich mir selber eine Infrastruktur aufbauen will, ist, glaube ich, die erste Frage, die ich mir stellen muss, was für eine Last diese Infrastruktur erwarten muss. Und dabei ist, glaube ich, die Kernfrage, brauche ich mehr als einen Server? Das muss man sich im Anfang einmal gut überlegen. Komme ich mit einem Server hin? So eine Frage ist bei Audio immer relativ schnell beantwortet, weil man doch heute für wenig Geld einen relativ großen Server bekommt und merkt, für 1000 Audio-Streams brauche ich vielleicht noch gar nicht mehr als einen Server, sondern ich brauche einfach nur einen, der an der vernünftigen Leitung hängt. Bei Video stellt sich das Problem schneller. Das heißt, bei Video bin ich doch irgendwie ab 100 Zuschauern, 150 Zuschauern, 300 Zuschauern, bin ich an der Grenze, was so ein Server liefern kann. Und dann stellt sich schnell so eine… Das ist quasi das, womit ich im Moment mein Geld verdiene. Also dafür sind wir da, solche Lösungen zu entwickeln.
Du gehst ja im Prinzip schon auf diese Cloud-Angebote von Amazon und so weiter, nutzt einfach da die Möglichkeit, dass man sich da mal eben temporär neue Büchse automatisch hochfahren kann und das dann entsprechend zu verteilen.
Genau, das ist Sex.
Aber das ist dann schon so richtig die tricky Variante, die man jetzt wahrscheinlich im überschaubaren Umfeld so für den Hobby-Streamer, Otto-Normal-Streamer. Braucht das erstmal nicht.
Was man noch einmal als interessanten Ansatz sagen kann an der Stelle, ich weiß, dass es das für Audio erfolgreich gab. Bei Video bin ich mir nicht sicher. Es gibt Peer-to-Peer-Streaming-Ideen. P2P-Cast. Ich glaube, in der Audiowelt hieß es P2P-Cast. Aber auch das oder Caster, müsste ich nochmal rauskommen. Es kann doch sein, dass es die inzwischen nicht mehr gibt. Ich weiß, dass das früher wahnsinnig attraktiv war. Und es ist technologisch ein hochinteressanter Ansatz zu sagen, ich habe diese Streaming-Infrastruktur, bringe ich einfach überhaupt gar nicht mit. Sondern ich will einfach, dass jeder Zuschauer selber auch das Signal mitverbreitet und sich damit so eine intelligente Wolke der Zuschauer selber...
So wie es gab, das ja im Prinzip auch ein bisschen Macht. P2P-Cast. P2P-Cast, Streaming-Protokolle.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall ganz interessant. Kann man mal am Auge behalten. Hatte halt den enormen Vorteil, dass ich gar keine Infrastruktur aufbauen muss. Allerdings meistens der Nachteil, dass die Zuhörer einen speziellen Client brauchen, der das unterstützt.
Ja, das ist das Problem. Die Sachen mit den Standards.
Ich glaube...
Ich glaube, wir haben es, oder? Das Thema ist jetzt endlich klar. Das war ein super schöner Überblick. Ich bin jetzt auch schon selber ein bisschen ins Grübeln gekommen, weil der eine oder andere Groschen gefallen ist, der die ganze Zeit immer so in der Luft kreiselte. Insofern, Ligur, vielen Dank.
Es hat mich sehr gefreut, hier zu sein.
Ja, mich auch. Und wir können jetzt hier gleich noch ein bisschen mit meinem Mixer rumspielen, mal gucken, was wir hier noch so gestreamt bekommen. Chaosradio Express gibt es nicht live, weil hier muss immer noch viel darüber nachgedacht werden, bevor das dann veröffentlicht wird. Wir werden noch ganz viele Links liefern zu all dem, was so gesagt wurde. Könnt ihr in die Show Notes gucken, das kennt ihr ja schon. Und deswegen ist das hier nicht unbedingt gerade so ein Live-Format. Aber ich denke halt, dass so ein Live-Radio und Live-Fernsehen, das sieht man ja jetzt schon, wird in zunehmendem Maße ein Volkssport werden. Und dieser technologische Weg, der sich da gerade abzeichnet, der kann eigentlich nur dabei helfen, dass das eben auch noch weiter da in die breite Masse kommt. Und das kann eigentlich auch nur ganz gut sein. Jeder ist ein Sender. Die alte Vision, wir kommen in zunehmendem Maße immer näher. Gut, dann nochmal danke. Und auch danke fürs Zuhören. Und das war euer Chaosradio Express.